Was wird hier gekackwadet?
Erst wird gepaarsed Champs, dann wird LUL 3D'd, Kack 3D'd und dann wird gekackwadet.
Ich fass es nicht hier.
Der Chat ist heute wieder frech, Alter.
Jetzt erlaubt sich der Chat heute wieder alles.
Kein cuter Chat.
Ne, äh, ja, ich hab mir gedacht, ich mach nochmal Stream an.
Deswegen basteln wir jetzt ein bisschen.
Ahja, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass der Stream online ist, ich lad mir mal kurz den Home
Assistant ISO runter, ich brauch ne Testinstallation.
Bis Twitch kapiert hat, dass das ganze on ist.
Installation Methods, Raspberry Pi, Generic, Vmware, Vmware, die haben doch irgendwo ein
Vmware Image.
Die haben doch irgendwo ein Vmware Image, warum die ein Vmware Image?
Wo haben sie denn das?
Wo ist das, wo ist das versteckt?
Vm, ja, Vm, da ist es doch, Virtual Box, Vmware Workstation, jawoll, komm her, exquisite.
Ja, doppelte Streamstalls, so sieht's aus.
Massiver Streamstalls.
Aber ich sag euch, also Chat, Chat, ich muss euch jetzt mal was erzählen, bevor es losgeht.
Genervt, nee, ich bin, ähm, ja, es hört sich bei mir immer genervt an, aber ich bin
nicht genervt.
Ich bin ein bisschen kaputt, ähm, deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, wir basteln jetzt noch
ein bisschen zusammen rum.
Quatsch, lul, lul, weh.
Bäm, high speed, weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, das auf dieser Festplatte zu
verwenden.
Ähm, ich nehm das mal lieber hier hin, äh, Moment, ich hab noch ne, ich hab noch ne Home
Assistant, Vm, Keg, wait, ich brauch das gar nicht neu installieren, Sack, Postchamp,
wait a minute, was?
Ah, G-Baded, G-Baded, G-Baded, sah nur so aus, ah, das sah nur so aus, aber ich könnte,
könnte das da jetzt einfach reinkopieren und dann die Festplatte umhängen und dann
starten.
Moment, jaja, cannot find, cannot find, kann ich das nicht so umhängen, add, Festplatte,
hard disk, SCSE, use physical disk, ne, use an existing virtual disk, e, Doppelpunkt,
Backslash, Vms, HA, ja, ich glaube ich hab das, ja, da ist es, zack.
Convert existing virtual disk to newer format, the chosen virtual disk can't be converted
to, ja, mach, müssen wir mal schauen, ob das jetzt funktioniert, ich muss das mal in
der Home Assistant umbedenken, sonst find ich das doch, find ich das doch lieber, HA.
So, ähm, während ich das jetzt hier, hier starte, alles klar, äh, kann ich euch mal
erzählen, was wir mal, Leute, ich muss mich, ich muss mich erstmal entspannen, ja, erstmal,
erstmal, VapeNation hier in der Runde, so, also, ne, ich rauch ja nix, wisst ihr ja,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. Amoin, Sekunde, Sekunde, amoin, warum überhaupt MQTT ist das nicht
überflüssig mit, nein, gar nicht, überhaupt nicht, die ganze automatische Device Discovery
läuft über MQTT, by Home Assistant, kann ich dir gleich zeigen, wenn ich gestartet
Die ganze Device Discovery, wir machen heute Auto, Auto, Auto Discovery, das sollte ich
vielleicht nochmal kurz in den Titel schreiben, M-Q-T-T-DIS-COVERY, ja okay, ja ich sollte
mal einen Browser aufmachen damit und zwar, das probiere ich mal, M-Q-T-T-DIS-COVERY,
Home Assistant, da steht es doch schon, ja habe ich euch schon mal gezeigt, so und damit
kann man nämlich, wenn man ein eigenes Gerät hat und kein Bock hat, da jetzt irgendwie
Home Assistant API mäßig überall das Passwort zu sharen oder, na gut, das M-Q-T-T Passwort
braucht man trotzdem oder das über die HTTP API zu machen, man kann das komplette Gerät
Auto-DIS-COVERN lassen oder über M-Q-T-T, dass der alles erkennt, vom Namen des Geräts
bis zu den Sensoren oder ich nenne es mal Sensoren, die am Gerät dran sind, also du
kannst beispielsweise ein komplettes, ich zeige es euch dann gleich wie das aussieht,
ein komplettes Gerät DIS-COVERN lassen, was zum Beispiel, gehen wir jetzt mal von der
Heizungssteuerung aus, die ich da integrieren will, ja, ich habe einen Raspberry Pi unten
im Keller, der die Steuerung von der Heizung machen kann, ja, der hat so ein serielles
Kabel, aufgereicht, genau, hat so ein serielles Kabel per USB angeschlossen, sowas da und
der kann steuern, der hat auch eine Software zum Steuern drauf, aber der braucht natürlich
Kommandos, was er machen soll, sonst kann er ja nur auslesen und auch das muss ihm sagen,
was er auslesen soll, das heißt, ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel über die M-Q-T-T-DIS-COVERY
komplett announcen lassen an Home Assistant, wo dann drinnen steht, ok, es gibt einen Switch
für Heizung umschalten, es gibt einen Sensor für Gerätenummer, es gibt einen Sensor für
Betriebsmodus, es gibt einen Sensor für Warmwassertemperatur und sowas, kann ja alles automatisch DIS-COVERN
anlassen, du musst nichts mehr machen, ja gut, dann erklär mir mal, wenn du meinst,
das geht, das würde damit gehen, dann erklär mir mal, wie willst du denn deine Heizungssteuerung
an ESP Home dran kriegen?
Das ist kein Microcontroller, das ist ein Raspberry Pi, ich weiß nicht, ob die mittlerweile
Raspberry Pis unterstützen, keine Ahnung, die ganze Zeit war das bisher immer nur die
unterstützten ESP32 und ESP866, ja es war heute echt anstrengend, das kannst du damit
nicht machen, ich zeig es euch, ja ich bin heute auch, also wir machen heute einen etwas
anderen Progress Stream, sag ich, wir machen das heute langsam und ordentlich, vielleicht,
vielleicht schreiben wir sogar die ein oder anderen Comments, wobei ich da noch meine
Zweifel habe, weil ihr wisst ja, guter Code kommentiert sich selbst, wenn nicht beim Stream,
ja, so, bin jetzt stehen geblieben, stimmt, also geht mal in Home Assistant Test vm jetzt,
ok, Home Assistant Landing Page, was habe ich denn für eine IP, ach guck mal da, 2133,
ok, ok, 122.133, wie Unable to Connect, Moment, das ist Home Assistant, das läuft auf dem
anderen Port, 8123, ach wow, warum sieht das so kacke aus, Dark Reader, lull, oh guck mal,
die haben jetzt ein neues Hintergrundbild, das kenne ich noch gar nicht, Name, Cute,
Username, Admin, Passwort, 123456, 123456, Create Account, nein, ja, ja, ja, da sind
wir genau da, ja, ja, ja, Currency, Euro, Time Zone, C-E-S-T, nein, C-E-T, Berlin, gut,
genau, alles klar, nein, nein, nein, nein, er hat Discovered, warum ist da ein Nächchen
dran, ach nee, das ist einfach nur ein Hinweis, Stay Locked In, yes, also, was ich heute machen
will, ach so, ich muss erstmal den MQTT Klein installieren, dann, das ist jetzt einfach
nur Vorbereitung, install, bam, nachher kommt wieder der Kokona Dosser, oh ja, kann sein,
bloß kein Kokona Dosser heute, oh, Configuration, Certificate, lull, weh, Alter, Zertifikate,
welches OS ist der, ist in der, das ist das offizielle Home Assistant OS Management Ding,
Certfile, wir brauchen keine Certfile, Certfile sind, offer, rated, debated, outdated, wir
machen Password Auth, Logins, MQTT, Integration, Home Assistant, das ist alles Setup, das hat
mit der eigentlichen Sache gar nichts zu tun, Logins, ich weiß nicht in welchem Format ich
das schreiben, nicht Login, Logins, Logins, hier, zeig mir die Syntax please, alles klar,
Untername, local user, define any, any MQTT Broker is just setup defaults, ok, das probieren
wir jetzt gleich aus, ob das funktioniert ohne Logins, save, was, fail to save, missing
option keyfiles, ok, dann lassen wir das halt da, save und start, jawoll, Configuration,
mal gucken ob das jetzt startet, die IP ist 127001, ja das ist das, die letzten aus Google
gelöscht werden sollte, ok, schauen wir mal, ob das MQTT Zeug jetzt läuft, Mosquito, Sub,
Hosts, Port, was ist MQTT Port 1883, ne, das ist einfach nur Hosts, Topic, Topic 0W, all
subscription requests were denied, na super, warum, warum, wo ist das Problem, warum, das
ist so eine wahnsinnig hilfreiche Fehlermeldung, Mosquito, danke für den Sub, Sub, haben wir
das schon mal verwendet, aha, WattChamp Total Energy, ah guck mal, es funktioniert, nice,
es funktioniert, das gleiche, aber vielleicht sollten wir nicht den Home, den, den, den,
den, ok, jetzt publishen wir mal kurz was, was ist das, was war das, Weihnacht, Weihnachtsnoups
sind zurück in Battlefield 3, null, warum habe ich nicht ein Video von mir runtergeladen,
Test Server, Publish, Sekunde, ich will einfach nochmal testen, ob alles funktioniert, Publish,
jetzt Message oder sowas hier, Clack, Clack, ne, Topic, Topic L, ja ok, Clack, Clack 3D,
alles klar funktioniert, gut, so, das muss uns jetzt alles nicht weiter interessieren,
wichtig ist, dass der Kram installiert ist und ich eine Testinstallation habe, also, was
wir jetzt probieren ist folgendes, wie gesagt, das ist eine Testinstallation von, ich muss
langsam machen Leute, ich muss mich, darf nicht so, dann bin ich, ich bin eh schon im Arsch,
wenn ich jetzt noch übelst enthousiastisch streben soll, dann bin ich voll im Arsch,
also langsam, langsam, das ist eine Testinstallation von Home Assistant, sieht man glaube ich,
weil da kaum was drin ist, also, hau bist du im Arsch, ja das ist ehrlich gesagt eine
gute Frage, ja, ich bin immer eine Stunde bisschen gelaufen, aber das war's, ne, ich
hab heute wieder viel im Haus rumgebaut und gemacht und geräumt, ja, nach dem Stream,
ich hab quasi vom Stream, wir waren fertig, 13.30, bis jetzt, von Stream eigentlich rumgebastelt
wieder, ja.
Hast du eigentlich Erfahrungen mit den Odroid Geräten, taugen die was, HA läuft bei mir
momentan auf dem Raspberry Pi, also, dazu kann ich dir was sagen, und zwar, erstens,
das liegt wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr am Raspberry Pi, sondern an der Micro SD Karte,
falls du das auf einer Micro SD Karte laufen hast, mach dir mal eine SSD dran, dann flutscht
das, der Raspberry Pi ist eigentlich schnell genug, die Odroid Geräte kannst du verwenden,
ich hab aber mit Home Assistant keine Erfahrung, ich hab auf einem Odroid HC2, hab ich TV Headend
für Fernsehaufnahmen zum Speichern, so, das ist dieses Ding mit dem Festplatten Einschub,
der funktioniert ganz gut, das ist quasi so ne eigene Festplatte, also ne eigenes Mini
NAS, was man sich bauen kann, weil da halt ein Festplatten Einschub ist, ja, aber mach
ne SSD dran, eh klar, USB, SATA SSD auf USB, kostet 2,50 Euro so ein Adapter, also wenn
du willst, dass es schnell läuft, mach ne SSD dran, es reicht ne billige SSD, muss nix
teures sein, ist aber auf jeden Fall sinnvoller als Micro SD, also was bei dir langsam ist,
ist wahrscheinlich die Micro SD Karte, bisschen Opftopic, hast du Erfahrung mit Linode gemacht,
nein, aber wenn wir gerade dabei sind, wenn es um gute Hosting Möglichkeiten geht, könnt
ihr in meinem Chat jetzt Ausrufezeichen Hetzner eingeben und dann mit meinem Startcode euch
20 Euro Startgutharmes sichern, aber passt mal auf, die sind jetzt ein Ticken teurer geworden,
Pricing, die sind jetzt bei den Standardpreisen ein bisschen teurer geworden, so 1 Euro 20
sind die ungefähr teurer geworden, weil die sagen, IPv4 Adressen sind teurer geworden,
was ich ja persönlich hoffe, ist, dass die vielleicht mal VMs anbieten komplett ohne,
wie sag ich die Musiklautstärke, so passt das, oder so einen Ticken leiser machen, Ticken
leiser vielleicht, was ich ja cool finden würde, wenn die anbieten würden, komplett ohne IPs,
das fände ich wirklich nice, ist geplant, woher weißt du das, arbeitest du da oder
hast du es gelesen, wo habe ich das angekündigt, ja, also wäre auf jeden Fall cool, weil dann
spare ich Geld, gelesen, ja, weiß, ich weiß leider immer noch nicht, wer dort bei Hetzner,
dass der Marketing Abteilung gesteckt hat, dass sie mich beanschreiben sollen wegen Sponsoring,
er hat sich nie wieder gemeldet, aber ich weiß, dass es eine aus dem Stream war, ich
frage mich immer noch, wer das war, jetzt hört man auch gerade keine Musik, weiß ich nicht,
wahrscheinlich 64 oder so, was ist denn die Fault, 64, ich habe keinen Schimmer, muss
mal nachgucken, hast du auch das Problem, dass bei dem bei den Xiaomi Temperatur und Luftfeudigkeit
sind mit Kasten geflecht die Uhrzeit pro Tag, ja, das mit der Uhrzeit kannst du vergessen,
das ist zu ungenau, ja, das gleiche Problem habe ich auch, also es geht um diesen, ja,
um diese kleinen Dinger hier geht es, sowas habe ich bei mir im Bad an der Wand hängen
und wir haben Kasten im Firmware drauf geflasht, Humidity heißt das auf Englisch, Github, ist
das ein Reap Thermometer, ja hier das da, das haben wir geflasht, das da unten, wobei
das glaube ich die alternative Firmware ist, ja, das da, ja, das haben wir geflasht, hier
so ein Teil und man kann da einstellen, dass das rotiert die Anzeige und zwar zwischen
Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit, Batteriestand, Wohlfühlanzeige oder irgendwie sowas, ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher was das sein soll, das ist irgendwie so eine Mischung aus Luftfeuchtigkeit
und Temperatur und wenn das Thermometer der Meinung ist, das ist quasi gut, dann zeigt
es so rum an oder ansonsten andersrum, ja, ein Schimmer, weiß noch immer, China-Chinesen-Zeug
halt, das Rebo-Meter, ja und da kannst du einstellen, dass es zusätzlich noch rotiert
Uhrzeit, das Problem ist nur, die Uhrzeit da drinnen ist mega schlecht umgesetzt, also
das hat anscheinend keinen genauen Timer drin, also kein Kristall oder irgendwie nix was da
richtig korrekt oszillatet, also das ist sehr ungenau was die Uhr angeht, meine Uhr ist
jetzt auch schon mittlerweile, keine Ahnung, 2 Stunden falsch oder so, das hat es, das
lohnt sich nicht, also die Uhrzeit kannst du knicken damit, das ist Müll, ich fand's
von der Idee her auch cool, noch ne zweite Uhr im Bad zu haben, aber das funktioniert
gar nichts, man könnte das einmal täglich sünken lassen von nem Bluetooth-fähigen,
sagen wir mal, ESP32 oder Raspberry Pi oder sonst wie, aber ich hab keinen Bock, die Uhrzeit
zu sünken auf das Thermostat, ich mein das sind schon richtige First World Problems,
mit Sünken auf das Thermostat im Bad über Bluetooth, ja, also wie gesagt ich bin heute
ein bisschen kaputt, deswegen machen wir das heute mal alles langsam und ordentlich, ich
wollte euch übrigens noch was fragen, chat ich hab mich ja heute morgen, wir haben heute
morgen den Walomart gemacht, ich weiß nicht ob ich sowas im Stream machen sollte, weil
ich hab immer die Bedenken, wenn ich das zeige, ich hab da keine Probleme mit zu zeigen
was ich mache, aber ich hab da so Bedenken, dass manche Leute sich irgendwie sinnloser
Weise da meiner Meinung anschließen, ohne sich das genauer selbst anzugucken, weil ich
hab von den meisten Sachen, ich sag das ja immer dabei, ich hab ja da selbst, ich kann
bei den meisten Sachen kaum wirklich informierte Entscheidungen treffen, es gibt ein paar
Themen, da kenn ich mich ganz gut mit aus, aber sag mal mal, 80% der Themen, ja, hab
ich, wenns hochkommt, irgendein Bauchgefühl, das sag ich zwar immer dabei, aber ich hab
so Bedenken, dass es Leute gibt, die dann sagen, ja, die machen das dann einfach wenn
ich das gesagt hab oder so, glaub mir, ich bin lang genug auf YouTube am Start, ich weiß,
dass das so ist, dass sich manche Leute einfach das anschließen, was mal jemand gesagt hat,
da nicht, dass das alle sind, wir haben natürlich hier wahnsinnig viele Big Prank Leute, aber
genauso wenig, wie du generell sagen kannst, die Zuschauer und damit immer alle genau
korrekt meinst, kannst du auch nicht sagen, dass es nicht so ist, ich weiß, dass es so
ist, ich weiß, dass es so ist, ich mein, das beste Beispiel ist doch immer noch, damals
der Flame War zwischen Playstation und Xbox, wie viele krasse Playstation Fanboys haben
mich angeflamt und wie viele Leute haben in den Kommentaren geschrieben, das ist der Max,
der hat Recht so nach dem Motto, es ist einfach so und ich hab kein Bock, dass die Leute einfach
nur, weil ich irgendwas gesagt hab, das der zu 1 zu 1 übernehmen, ja, ich muss sagen,
ich fand den aktuellen auch ein bisschen doof, da waren auch viele Sachen so vage, du konntest
gar nicht genau sagen, worum ging es da bei dem Tempolimit zum Beispiel, welches Tempolimit
genau und was mein, das fand ich auch nicht so schön diesmal gemacht, die Fragen müssen
so klar sein, dass man da was zu sagen kann, mal gucken, aber das kommt ja auf die Zuschauerbase
an, damals waren so, jaja, das heißt aber nicht, dass das irgendwie heute anders wäre,
es sind vielleicht nicht mehr so viele, aber es gibt immer noch genug und ich merke das
ja auch selbst, wenn ich von manchen Sachen keine Ahnung habe, aber so ein gewisses Bauchgefühl
und ich guck mir dann in ein Video an, wo einer das Bauchgefühl, was ich hatte, quasi
relativ logisch vertritt, dann sag ich sofort, zuerst mal instinktiv, ah ja, ich wusste
doch, da ist was dran, dabei kann der Typ mir mega scheiß erzählen, ja, ich weiß nicht,
ich weiß nicht, aber ist auch egal, wir machen jetzt, progress stellt, ne, da geht es ja nicht
darum, ob das jetzt richtig oder falsch ist, ich hab nur keinen Bock, dass Leute das einfach
nachmachen oder jetzt quasi das genauso sehen, nur weil ich das gesagt hab und das ist halt
im Internet leider so, das hast du im Internet einfach und das ist, klar, das mag bei mir
vielleicht nicht so sehr sein wie bei, was weiß ich, Montana Black oder so, wo ganz viele
Junge sind, aber gut, bei dem sind es natürlich auch noch viel mehr, aber das ist auch bei
mir so, tja, und das ist tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht, ob das so sinnig ist, ja, das
wäre tatsächlich mal ganz interessant, so, aber, nichtsdestotrotz, lange Rede, kurzer
Video, ja, nichtsdestotrotz, also, was wir jetzt machen ist folgendes, ich hab hier eine
Test Home Assistant installiert und wir haben da jetzt keine Discovery Devices und ich hab
das MQTT Addon installiert, also, was ich hab ist, ich hab im Keller ein Raspberry Pi
stehen, ich glaube, der hier, ich hoffe, ich hab das noch richtig, hoffe, ich hab das noch
richtig, 11-Hat-Pi, alles klar, ist das der richtige, ja, das ist der richtige, wie viele
Pies hast du bei dir zu Hause, also, die, die dauerhaft im Betrieb sind, sind jetzt, glaube
ich, lass mal kurz überlegen, 3D Drucker, der im Keller, der im Wohnzimmer unten, der
Zero mit der Kamera, ich glaube, das waren alle, die standardmäßig in Benutzung sind,
ich bin dir ein, ich hab noch eins Zero vergessen, ich bin dir ein, ich hab zwei Raspberry Pi
Zero, aber ich komm grad nicht drauf, ach ne, den zweiten Zero hatte ich im Keller, den
hab ich jetzt aber durch den hier ersetzt, ja, ja, so sieht es aus, genau, ich glaube,
vier Stück, hast du eigentlich mal den 8GB Raspberry Pi bestellt? Gute Frage, ich glaube
schon einfach nur weil es geht, aber es ist nicht sinnvoll, den 8GB Raspberry Pi zu kaufen.
Ich glaube dafür gibt- ne ne ne hab ich nicht bestellt, 4GB war das größte, weil der 8GB
nicht lieferbar war, worum. Ist aber sinnlos, würde ich nicht empfehlen. Ich sehe keinen
Grund darin 8GB Raspberry Pi zu kaufen. Ja, also ich glaube, glaube 4 Stück, dazu kommen
noch etliche ESP´s, dann O-Troid im Wohnzimmer. Ja, ist schon, ist schon ein paar Sachen.
Also ich hab hier den Raspberry Pi, da läuft die Steuerung für die Heizung drauf, so und
den müssen wir jetzt ansprechen. Was? Ich hab so eine semi-smarte Heizungssteuerung,
also nicht halbes und nix ganzes. Kamerlauter, wirklich, äh, proprietäres Zentralthermostat
und so. Da würde ich mal gucken, ob es nicht eine Möglichkeit gibt, weil das, so wie ich
das gemacht hab, das ist ja auch alles andere als offiziell. Ja, also ich verwende hier
GitHub. Ups. V-Control-D. Das ist auch für Wiesmann-Heizung ein Open Source Programm,
was dieses offizielle Wiesmann-Protokoll integriert hat. Das ist auch nix offizielles.
Also du kannst, du kannst mal gucken, ob es da für deine Sache nix gibt. Die Chancen
stehen denke ich mal sogar ganz gut. Dipp. Weiß ich nicht, ich hab gerade geupdatet,
soll ich mal, soll ich mal alles refreshen? Oh, da ist was verschwunden, habt ihr das gesehen?
Was ist denn da verschwunden? Ah nee, jetzt ist wieder da. Ah, IP-Leak. Die IP ist verschwunden.
Home Assistant hat doch Wiesmann. Das ist ein guter Hinweis. Ich kann dir aber mal zeigen,
wo das Problem ist. Sekunde. Configuration Integrations. Das kann ich jetzt mal zeigen,
weil nicht immer nur, weil der Hersteller da auftaucht. Nee, hatte, haben sie nicht,
haben sie nicht drinne. Nur weil der Hersteller da auftaucht, ist das gut. Also wenn du mir
das GitHub-Projekt sagst, dann kann ich dir dazu sagen, warum es nicht geht. Aber die
Integrations, die ich kenne, die gehen über die Wiesmann Cloud. Das heißt, das geht nur,
wenn du eine Wiesmann-Heizung hast mit irgendeinem Smart-Geldwert ran in die Cloud, mit einem
Account und die Integration ruft dann über die Cloud deine Daten ab und pusht über die Cloud quasi
die Daten zu deiner Heizung. Das ist natürlich bescheuert. Ich will das lokal haben. Ich sehe
es nicht ein, dass meine Heizung in irgendeiner Art und Weise von der Cloud oder vom Internetzugang
abhängig ist. Also ich weiß, nennt mich da irgendwie old school, aber nee. Ja und selbst
wenn das lokal ist, brauchst du da irgendein komisches Gerät von denen dafür. Nee, nee,
das ist nix. So und Configure, das müssen wir jetzt noch machen. Jaja, Submit. Haben wir,
haben wir alles gemacht, alles gut. Configuration, Integrations, MQTT. Also was man jetzt machen kann
ist folgendes. Ich habe ja im Keller den Raspberry Pi für die Heizungssteuerung. Da läuft,
da läuft ein Programm drauf mit seriellem, was den seriellen Adapter für die Heizung anspricht.
So und das Ding will ich jetzt steuern. Am besten mit einem zweiten Programm,
was dann auch da drauf läuft und das steuert. Aber das kann man auch über das Netzwerk steuern.
Und dann möchte ich, dass Home Assistant diesen alles, was man Raspberry Pi so ausschließt,
quasi automatisch importiert bekommt über die MQTT Discovery. Und da gibt es so ein extra
so eine extra Convention, wie man MQTT Messages gestalten muss, damit Home Assistant dieses Gerät
erkennt. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt mein Raspberry Pi, dieses Programm von Raspberry Pi zum
Beispiel exportieren lassen einen Switch, das dann hier wirklich als Schalter auftaucht. Einen
Switch, der Heizung an und ausschaltet und ein Sensor für alle möglichen Temperaturdaten und
sowas. So und das kann ich autodiscoveren lassen über das MQTT Addon. Das probieren wir jetzt
gleich aus. Aber damit das Ganze funktioniert, muss ich natürlich erst mal was programmieren,
was aus meiner Heizung überhaupt beziehungsweise aus diesem Programm über Telnet. Wir reden hier
von Oldschool Heizungstechnik. Wir machen das selbstverständlich über Telnet. Was über
Telnet beziehungsweise was heißt Telnet? Über den TCP Socket die Daten auslesen kann. Ich kann
euch auch zeigen, wie das funktioniert. Also wenn ich jetzt hier Telnet 122.168.133.1250.
Es ist 825. Wie Kontroll, wie Port, was ist für ein Port? Wie Kontroll, wie, was ist für ein Port?
3002.
3002 SSH, Netstat, was läuft denn da so 3002
Reboot
mal gucken vielleicht habe ich irgendwie kaputt gemacht oder so wir lassen den einfach mal
Reboot mal schauen mal schauen wenn es nach dem Reboot nicht geht dann mache ich mir Gedanken
ja da ist er wieder es ist übrigens jetzt sehr gewagt gewesen den neu zu starten weil sonst
hätte ich in Keller rennen müssen wenn er nicht neu gestartet wäre so also es bin wie
control die fort 3002 was ist blöd ach die ip ist falsch ich kacke noob das ist ja mein lokal
home assistant server ich bin ich bin verwirrt leute 1.29 so ist richtig falsche ip ja ja
blödsinn guck mal hier telnet so zack kriegt man eine telnet session da kommt dann so ein
Mist bei raus und dann kann man sowas sagen wie hier passt mal auf also die diese Wiesmann
software das ist denklich wie sagt man so schön par excellence ja get betrieb art enter warm
wasser oder es gibt dann sowas wie get warm wasser ist gut wie auch immer das heißt müsste
ich nachgucken das ist wirklich grausam ist was die sich da ausgedacht haben ich glaube
es ist get wie wie ist temp ane get temp wie wie ist get temp wie wie ist fast richtig
get temp wie wie ist das ist monach es richtig das ist hardcore monach es und vor allem guckt
euch mal an wie grausam der output formatiert ist 73.701 grad Celsius das zu passen wird
wahrscheinlich richtig abfakt ja also ihr merkt das ist heizungstechnik das ist old school
as fuck natürlich geht es über telnet was sonst das heißt wir müssen jetzt erstmal
ein telnet quitt hat funktioniert poggers obvius obvius ich finde es ist absolut obvius
dass dir das hier nicht geht und das funktioniert logisch ach ja und ich habe im titel stehen
wir machen das ganze mit dotnet 6 ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob es überhaupt den dotnet
6 repo gibt ich wollte es nämlich schon mit dotnet 6 machen weil dotnet 6 kommt bald raus
wusste der so auf dotnet 6 release date gar nicht mehr lange ich glaube im november 9
november zwei monate noch das dotnet 6 am start wie der frazier immer gesagt hat am
start ich weiß gar nicht hat der fabian in letzter zeit mal gestreamt sagt er das immer
noch am start a ja weep games hat er gestreamt weep games alter a ja ja weep games guckt euch
das an weep games oft du mir kocher epic 7 pay to win weep games pay to win mobile weep
games gibt es eigentlich was schlimmeres in kombination aber jedem was im spaß macht
ne fabian meint ja auch er kann sich gar nicht erklären dass mir das game nicht gefällt
und das mögen das mag sogar sein dass mir das gefallen würde aber allein schon weil
es irgendwie paid to win mobile game ist habe ich da kein bock drauf also ich wollte mal
kurz gucken gibt es einen dotnet 6 repo für by the way linux our dotnet 6 ist da sowas
haben die sowas vielleicht schon nach was muss ich suchen dort wahrscheinlich dotnet
einer ein repo für gemacht 5 5 5 hier 6 preview 7 perfekt das brauchen wir mal gucken ob er
das darüber installieren kann ansonsten muss ich da irgendwie das lokale das install script
nehmen also was brauchen wir denn 12 13 was oder und so was warum ist das stk 2 noch drin
wenn es konfliktet muss ich das e was dort hat haus preview dotnet haus preview was haus
ich glaube ich glaube wir machen das ins mit dem install script das war was get dotnet oder
sowas get get dotnet script in die dot dot punkt nett so war das ja wir machen das wir
machen das mit dem install script und ihr wisst ja einfach immer immer solche scripts nehmen
solche scripts nehmen und nach bashpipen ganz wichtig einfach immer ungesehen all
wo ist das problem na gut da weget weget weget kann das auch
gut dotnet install dotnet install dotnet install so und jetzt minus c preview oder sowas
ne minus c channel minus c preview minus c preview guck ob das funktioniert ne minus
minus channel guck ob das jetzt funktioniert ne alter dotnet install preview script was ist
denn der richtige channel ich muss das kleinschreiben kann das sein muss das kleinschreiben
ha 6.0 ok und woher weiß ich was jetzt die richtige und woher weiß ich jetzt was die
richtige ist channel 6.0 what kann ich einfach sagen channel 6 latest oder so woher weiß
ich denn jetzt was richtig ist install instructions zeig mal her microsoft snap
nein egal was ich mache ich verwende da kein snap für install dotnet preview punkt sh
da ja meinetwegen gibt es das da tatsächlich dann nehme ich halt das script meinetwegen
warum auch immer das mit dem offiziell nicht geht das ist mehr soll mir recht sein will
ich will anfangen alles plus es gibt auch noch nichts zu verstehen weil ich selbst nicht
verstehe die machen es einem aber echt schwer die machen es einem aber echt schwer den
shit zu installieren
ah ah guck mal hier ne das ist snap muss ich das wirklich über snap installieren ja
ich installiere das ich installiere es nicht über snap die neid alter was spricht gegen
das aber ich vermute das konfliktet mit den mit dem schon installierten aber es kann doch
nicht sein dass ich zu dumm bin install dotnet 6 da muss es doch was anstehen script ja das
hatten wir doch gerade schon vielleicht muss ich das da vielleicht muss ich das da angeben
dotnet 6 preview channel ne alter
also da muss man da muss man echt sagen microsoft ist er da wirklich massive brain ich habe
keine ahnung wie ich das offizielle install script den den den kram installiere hochkomplex
ich habe snap installiert ich will aber snap nicht verwenden das kriegen wir jetzt raus
minus minus channel 6.0 beta wirklich das war doch bei snap das war doch bei snap das
war doch nicht für das script ok ok wir kriegen das ich kriege das raus ich frage reddit reddit
weiß ja bekanntlichermaßen alles
minus minus quality preview also wenn das jetzt funktioniert dann lach ich dann lach
ich microsoft wirklich aus quality will be ignored wir installieren einfach 31 microsoft
wunderbar habt ihr sehr gut gemacht sehr gut sehr gut richtig richtig nice hallo wo ist
das problem aber warum ist es so kompliziert
ich bin komplett lost alter ich bin ich bin komplett lost ich weiß nicht wie ich sie installieren
kriege dort ist ich sehe da kein example ok da gucken wir noch mal gucken wir noch mal
hier sehen wir jetzt halt doch jeder drüber 12 13 15 15 minus minus quality preview channel
current ok das ist das 5er sdk so minus minus channel 6 ok ok jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt wollen
wir es wissen hier was minus minus quality preview wahnsinn da musste erst mal drauf
kommen also microsoft ist wirklich hier monka stier alter was was darf ich was sie da wieder
gebaut haben also kompliziert hätte man das nicht machen kann übrigens nur mal so
als so ein vorschlag an an microsoft was ganz unten ist ein example wo denn hier ich
hätte da mal einen vorschlag an microsoft man könnte einfach ein menü machen ein konsolen
menü zum installieren und dann würde es einfach funktionieren 6 punkten was war das
6 punkt das ist das ist angeblich im das hätte ich nie das hätte ich nie als beispiel interpretiert
was man da so eingeben muss aber das ist das ist anscheinend das aktuelle sieben preview
sieben ist das ist das aktuelle dotnet 0 100 preview sieben das ist das war egal jetzt
können wir endlich anfangen jawoll hat nur 30 milliarden stunden gedauert nope viel
nope man soll es schauen wir mal ob reiter den kram auch erkennt ist settings tool sets
ha guck mal reiter ist big brain deswegen mag ich dieses chat brains zeug die denken mit
natürlich das ist auch der standard installationsfahrt aber die denken mit das
das mag ich bei das mag ich bei denen monopro nicht dass das mag ich bei denen die denken
mit wir können jetzt neue c sharp 6 features verwenden dotnet c sharp 10 features verwenden
leider habe ich schon wieder alle aus diesem preview video was ich geguckt habe vergessen
wir fallen jetzt keine ein aber die hatten diesmal wirklich ein paar coole paar coole
neue features dabei also gerade bei asp9 diese minimal api finde ich nice aber die
hatten auch so ein paar ziemlich gute ziemlich gute c sharp 10 features
global using directives filescope namespace declarations extended property allow constat
das ist ganz praktisch das ist gut das ist richtig gut man braucht dieses ganze namespace
und eine einrückungstiefe nicht das finde ich cool ja man kann best tieferes pattern
matching irgendwie machen das nutze ich äußerst selten constant interpolated strings mit was
will ich in die interpolaten wenn die constant sind das verstehe noch nicht so genau record
types cancel to string mich auch nicht das ist das ist cool du kannst so tuppelzuweisung
machen direkt direkt aus dem objekt das ist ganz praktisch das macht es ein bisschen kürzer
das gucken wir uns an wenn es soweit ist also console app wie heißt das ding heitschamp
oder der heitschamp ist am start solutions directory cacv as a service nein writer projects
so heitschamp chat sprains ist 5 hat und plot gleichzeitig ja das stimmt das ding ist ziemlich
bloatet aber 5 hat bloatet so language c-sharp 10 und dotnet 6 docker support nein docker
super das wäre auch eine möglichkeit gewesen wir hätten den offiziellen 6er preview docker
container nehmen können dafür das wäre auch next level shit gewesen was ist f-sharp f-sharp
ist eine funktionale programmiersprache für das dotnet framework von microsoft hat hat
guck mal das ist übrigens das neue das ist das was ihr hier seht ist ein neues c-sharp
11 12 10 alter meine güte c-sharp 10 feature man braucht jetzt diesen ganzen boilerplate
shit nicht mehr guck mal das ist jetzt das kleinste c-sharp programm was man machen
kann das ist fast so kurz wie in den python programm was der unter der haube macht ist
der generiert natürlich auch ein main und sowas guck wenn ich das jetzt ausführe da
darf ich aber nicht dotnet run sagen sondern muss sagen dotnet dotnet run das auch im 6er
läuft was denn jetzt schon wieder we're not found ok export also der installer ist schon
ist schon schlecht export framework konnte man auch irgendwo machen wie ging das nochmal
oder framework root oder irgendwie sowas wie waren das nochmal da musste man noch irgendwas
exportieren dass das funktioniert das ist aber alles weil das halt bring the preview
version ist gut export was waren das nochmal hier export da steht export
das muss doch das muss doch in dem install skript stehen das install
ist die musik aus export steht da also nicht drinne ok ach was war das denn nochmal man
muss dem sagen wo das ist ok vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht das ist auch schon gereicht normalerweise
da steht das doch dabei i could not find bla bla bla was war das denn export framework root
oder sowas aber wie ging das denn das export kann ich das kann ich das in der ide starten
mal gucken ob das prinzipiell funktioniert ja das funktioniert ok
es ist alles es ist schon alles drauf bei microsoft findest du auch wieder nix framework
sdk dotnet sdk export linux installieren von dotnet unter ubuntu dotnet genau es ist
nicht dotnet file es ist es ist dotnet sdk oder irgendwie sowas warum findet man dann
da wieder nix alter diese dotnet root das suche ich die ganze zeit export dotnet root
genau das brauchen wir dotnet root ist dotnet alter das ist ja wirklich also microsoft tut
sich da echt schwer mit hier dotnet glaube ich es reicht wahrscheinlich schon so archlinux
wiki genau export dotnet reicht das reicht das einfach so was achso gleich meine shell
ist übrigens übrigens verbugt hier gerade wo ist denn jetzt das problem schon wieder
also ich will jetzt einfach mal anfangen kann es kann es jetzt mal please gehen microsoft
moin keiner hi ich meine ich muss ja alles installiert haben weil es funktioniert ja
es geht ja es läuft ja in die idee ok glaube ich net es ist sdk der richtig echte aguilet
ok ich habe leute ich habe keinen schimmer was microsoft hier von mir will warum das
so wahnsinnig komplex wieder ist den den shit installiert zu bekommen das leuchtet mir wieder
nicht ein zumal dass das offizielle das offizielle install script ist aber wo haben wir denn das
wo haben wir das install script hier laufen lassen er sagt er sagt hier noch ads adding
to your current pass home dotnet ok mach ich mach ich mach ich also pass pass home max
keck www alles klar das das das promma das ist ganz wichtig shell neu starten als champ
ich kann auch ich kann heute echt nicht schreiben ja ja user bin das ist auch ok net run das
juckt es einfach nicht rider meint in sechser ja ja ich habe ein sechser installiert passt
ja auch läuft ja auch hier ich habe bloß beim besten bilden keine ahnung was ich für
was ich für wie ich dem auf der command line erzählen kann dass er das sechser verwenden
soll was unter hier im home verzeichen installiert ist wirklich keinen blassen schimmer ja gibt
es den befehl bestimmt export dotnet gut habe ich schon gemacht so gleich home max dotnet
ah hatte ich das nicht gerade schon gemacht und dann ging es nicht oder muss ich das immer
als absoluten fahrt angeben alles klar ok exzellent wunderbar funktioniert du hast aber
auch die shell neu gestartet ja weil ich den pass gesetzt habe das liegt wahrscheinlich
daran weil ich vorher sowas hier gesagt habe das geht wahrscheinlich nicht das geht nicht
ok man muss es absolut machen dann funktioniert es na gut meinetwegen alles gut lasse ich
mir jetzt einleuchten so das hier ist neues 5 hat 11 hat c sharp 10 feature dass man jetzt
seinen main nicht mehr braucht aber ich weiß nicht ist da irgendwie die compiler in rider
drin überhaupt nicht oder sonst würde ich euch das ganze ganze mal zeigen aber hier
irgendwie dotnet die compiler installieren zeige euch mal was das macht er scheint rechts
il viewer wobei ich nicht il viewen will ich will zurück also ich will mir nicht il angucken
sondern das zurück übersetzt in c sharp haben dotpeak ist glaube ich windows only geht das
hier kann man das hier zurück desassemble will ich haben genau desassemble dass ich
ich wollte euch eigentlich zeigen dass der hier eine neue main methode macht compile
und dann die compile ja genau aber ich weiß nicht wie ich die compile mache keine ahnung
die compile methods es gibt eine neue kategorie software und game development ernsthaft muss
jetzt mal ausprobieren which software and game development da gehen wir da rein programming
grills alles klar und wir sind in science and technology aus auf twitch da sind wir
leute leute wir wechseln wir wechseln mal muss ich mal ausprobieren ob das jetzt funktioniert
software software and game development testen wir mal wo es mehr viewer gibt gut ich habe
keine ahnung writer des decompile ob das funktioniert explore und decompile assemblies
ja zeig her solution aha aha solution assemblies nothing to show perfekt add open vom gag open
hides champ bin äh wo ist mein kompiliertes hier das da hides hides dll metadata alter
what the fuck ich will einfach nur das das ist mit das ist mir zu zu zu feifert ich will
einfach nur dass die compile sehen und warum sind da win 32 resources drinne 6 hat time
hast du das bei dir auch via ems interface realisiert oder was bei ich habe ein serielles
kabel dran für vom hersteller bei info rot led an der raspberry pile ok kein schimmer
ehrlich gesagt blicken blicken immer durch das ist mir ist mir zu advanced anscheinend
das ganze hier ah hier ne references kann man sich nicht den decompile angucken ob man
close assemblies das muss doch funktionieren explore und decompile you can double click
any type to decompile it or fetch source from a symbol server ok any type kann ich anklicken
wo weiß ich jetzt was dann ein type ist ich bin meh a ja das kann ich die compile ja gut
das will ich ja nicht ich will mein eigenes zeug die compile ich will mein eigenes zeug
die compile hier ist der heist champ heist champ so und wo ist jetzt wo ist jetzt ok
warte mal ich gebe jetzt ich mache jetzt da was ein also irgendwie kann public anehm
wie macht man das jetzt überhaupt drinne heck weh so ich muss ja klasse moment also
das leuchtet jetzt nicht ein public class heck weh so public void lull ok so und das
compile ich jetzt oder runne das jetzt wie auch immer dort peak kann das ich weiß ich
weiß so reloaded das jetzt automatisch oder muss ich das jetzt noch mal hinzufügen gucken
wir mal heist champ und die dl macht jetzt einfach alles auf heist champ warum stehen
da meine eigenen typen nicht drin muss ich das jetzt muss ich das hier assembly das
ist ich bin da ich bin da nicht high iq genug dieses tool zu verwenden glaube ich type def
heck weh ich hab keine ahnung wie das funktioniert eigentlich wollte ich euch nur zeigen dass
der nach wie vor eine main methode generiert obwohl man das jetzt kürzer schreibt keine
ahnung wie auch immer wir machen wir machen jetzt einfach mal weiter also wir haben wir
haben ja wieder viel rum rum gebastelt die class wird nicht kompiliert weil die nicht
verwendet werden das kann natürlich sein das ist richtig dann rufen dann rufen wir das
jetzt auf new heck weh lull so perfekt run ja man sieht das auch man sieht das auch hier
im el viewer ja aber ich fände es halt schöner wenn man das die compile sieht dann dann
so hier assemblies muss man das jetzt neu adden oder oder oder leider das jetzt automatisch
also als gemmeter data filter what da fuck ich krieg hier alles angezeigt nur nicht mein
eigenes zeug guckt euch das man das ja ist ja voll gestört da blickst nicht durch kann
es auch hier nichts öffnen oder so ist anscheinend wirklich für für fremdes für fremdes zeug
gedacht ok passt mal auf wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt 6 hat heim ich leg jetzt eine
neue console app an und da öffne ich das jetzt drin assemblies ich frag mich ob das
besser ist ich habe alles geöffnet ich habe alles geöffnet so jetzt hier add open als
champ jawoll aha da steht jetzt drin die exe kompilierst du nicht unter linux doch doch
das ding heißt das ding heißt oftmals auch noch dl und sowas unter unter linux obwohl
es ja schwachsinnig ist das ist halt microsoft benahmung guck hier so hier ist top entry
level point das ist mein programm die compile das sieht für die compile zu original aus
doch das ist anscheinend wirklich die heitschepprogramm da ist so schlau und kann das öffnen blies
in rider nicht so viel mitdenken nicht so viel mitdenken nicht nicht big brain sein
einfach anzeigen ok scheiß drauf wir machen jetzt heiter heitschepp wir machen jetzt wir
machen jetzt heitschepp hör mal auf geb ihm die bedingsfiles nicht ne ich mach jetzt wir
machen jetzt heitschepp wir machen jetzt heitschepp also wie gesagt das ist ein neues feature
warum kann man das nicht kompilieren was sagt er das programm macht nichts sagt er wahrscheinlich
oder das not konter ok ich muss bei wo sind denn die sind dann die snippets funktionieren
die snippets vielleicht nicht las funktionieren die snippets vielleicht hier nicht ja die
snippets funktionieren sind auch ein bug in rider kann man jetzt auch functions außerhalb
vom klassen definieren ja ne kann man nicht das hier ist eigentlich auch ganz normal namespace
heitschepp public static main was hier drumherum gebaut wird das ist das was ich euch eigentlich
zeigen wollte aber was rider mich euch nicht zeigen lässt das ist einfach nur syntaktisch
syntaktisch bisschen schöner das baut für dich da in main drumherum du kannst zum beispiel
auch nicht zwei files machen immer kurz weg du kannst zum beispiel auch nicht zwei files
machen und sagen wir da jetzt mal console right line 1 2 3 4 so das funktioniert nicht
wenn du das jetzt probierst dann sagt er dir also der macht den main da drumherum oder
jetzt weiß er nicht ob er das hier als main nehmen soll oder das hier als main nehmen soll
das ist einfach nur syntaktisch zucker ist aber ganz cool muss ich sagen ok jetzt jetzt
machen wir mal ein bisschen jetzt machen wir mal ein bisschen was sinnvolles also wir wollen
jetzt den mein heizungs mein heizungskram ansprechen also heizungskram ist was war das
1 2 1 6 1 2 1 2 9 so also wie können wir das ganze machen ich habe gesagt wir machen
es langsam und schön heute mal ok also machen wir eine class public class v-client haben
wir schon mal gemacht für den prometeuse exporter ich kann mich dran erinnern so v-client dann
schieben wir das in eine extra in ein extra file warum kann es das nicht konnte man das
nicht in extra feil schieben lassen refector des move to another file v-client cs ah das
wegen kann er das nicht die supporten das mit top levels die haben noch ein bisschen
probleme mit mit top level top level stels ok da machen wir machen wir das so dass das
müsste jetzt eigentlich checken v-client.cs ja ok ok passt so weil so sieht das standardmäßig
aus was wir jetzt aber hier machen können ist wir können jetzt sagen using wie geht
das nee nee nee nicht using namespace können wir jetzt sagen namespace namespace hideschamp so und ich glaube so geht das jetzt im 90 chap 10 oder ohne semi colon nee warte mal wie geht das jetzt da muss ich
noch mal nachgucken das stand hier in der was denn c-chap 10 what's new das using files
scope namespace decklöcheln namespace my namespace ja ist doch richtig wo ist wo hatte
was hat er jetzt vor schmerzen hat keine schmerzen rider kann das einfach noch nicht ok writer
hat einfach das feature eingebauten denkt es wäre kaputt das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof aber
klar während das noch in entwicklung ist haben die das noch nicht alles drinne da
müsste man jetzt visual studio preview version verwenden dann würde das wahrscheinlich funktionieren
also das ist jetzt neu man spart einmal einmal ein rückungstiefe was ich persönlich äußerst
nice finde kann man sich leider auf die error anzeigen nicht verlassen kann ich ihm einfach
sagen ignore error wenn man dem nicht irgendwie sagen darf nicht so oder auch nicht kann die
rider beta das bin ich mir nicht sicher inspekt juckt juckt ihn aber bei der anzeige nicht jetzt
aber auch egal es funktioniert ja also das ist das ist jetzt neues das ist wie gesagt
der rider kennt das einfach noch nicht vielleicht lasse ich das jetzt auch weil ich habe keinen
bock dass es mir laufenden fehler anzeigt wir machen das jetzt machen wir machen die
klassische wir machen die klassische variante das ist auch nicht ohne semi kohle und es ist
einfach noch nicht eingebaut in rider dass es das kann so also wunderbar also dass das ist
ziemlich oldschool telnet wie ich euch gezeigt habe hier telnet das heißt was wir jetzt machen
müssen ist und ich habe ich jetzt gekillt hoffentlich so also das ist oldschool oldschool telnet das
heißt wir brauchen jetzt in tcp socket dass das ganze funktioniert also wie machen wir
das denn jetzt ach ja und es gibt noch was um die ganze sache noch ein bisschen komplizierter
zu machen das ding kann kommandos seriell also nacheinander ausführen mehrere mehrere
hintereinander also sprich wenn ich das so mache hier get betrieb art ja ich weiß pence
champ namen dann ist es relativ langsam aber was ich machen kann ist in der gleichen telnet
lull please in der gleichen telnet session mehrere sachen ausführen dann geht schnell
guck get betrieb art ist langsam gewesen aber wenn ich noch mal was ausführen ist es schneller
und es ist nicht nur get betrieb art sondern es geht auch gibt auch get inventory oder oder
nee keine ahnung get wie was war das get temp ww ist gibt es auch noch ja das geht jetzt das
geht jetzt schnell weil das alles in der gleichen session ist also das heißt wir müssen diesem
kleinen auch noch irgendwie beibringen wenn man mehrere kommandos hat dass er die alle schön der
reihe nach ausführt aber nach möglichkeit innerhalb von einer tcp session detail nein man kann den
worker auch nicht am leben lassen weil das weil das rum backt wenn man den zu lange aufmacht wenn
man den zu lang offen hat das beendet irgendwann das habe ich schon mal ausgesprochen das beendet
an irgendwann random die die die verbindung und nimmt keine mehr an also man muss das man muss
das wirklich ganz korrekt öffnen kommandos ausführen und dann wieder schließen sonst
sonst backt rum englische denglische kommandos ja da wie es man dachte sich oder der implementierer
dieser open source auslese lösung dachte sich get ww get temp ww ist ist eine gute idee hat
er sich so gedacht ok also was was brauchen wir denn dass das ganze funktioniert also ich würde
sagen wir brauchen auf jeden fall ein ip oder sowas aus der string aus aus zwing port alle ich
kann wieder richtig gut schreiben aus zwing port oder wir sind richtig big brain und nehmen entweder
socket address oder ip address aber wir nehmen ip endpoint das ist glaube ich noch besser ip end
point ist der ist der five hat move da ist ip und port glaube ich schon mit drinne das ist das ist
der big brain move also endpoint ob da ist nämlich sport und und address schon drinne
ip endpoint ok so den speichern wir uns zack und jetzt rufen wir das ding schon mal auf in
in unsere main dass wir wissen ob es funktioniert new wie clients und da brauchen wir ein endpoint
ist der endpoint so schlau und kann irgendwie von string konvertiert werden wir sind ja hier nicht
in c++ wobei habe ich gerade habe ich gerade c++ und schlau in irgendwie ein einem zusammenhang
erwähnen das war das das war das war nicht so gemeint also du musst massive brain sein für
c++ aber c++ an sich ist nicht gut wenn du bist heute jebaited am stand ne ne das mit c++ meine ich ernst c++
ist der letzte shit es gibt kaum was was ich weniger mag als c++ gibt übrigens auch jetzt
seit ein paar seit ein paar c sharp versionen ein neues feature früher musste man immer sowas hier
machen new endpoint und dann konnte musste man hier die graben reinschreiben was mittlerweile geht
ist new und dann einfach nur klammern und da ist er so schlau und check das so und jetzt und jetzt
kann ich das kann ich das da kann ich das hier anlegen also new wobei da jetzt ip endpoint zu
nehmen ist ganz schön rede minute kann ich dann muss ich jetzt ip pass machen ganz ehrlich das
ist mit zwei strings dann doch einfacher ja das ist richtig das hat nicht wie man gemacht das
hat diese open source implementierungs tut typen da gemacht gibt es sowas wie ip endpoint pass oder
sowas ip endpoint ja so ist das doch fein so mag ich das so mag ich das so ist das nice
so wunderbar wieder was gelernt da gibt es jetzt eben wenn ich jetzt hier nämlich mist reinschreibt
zum beispiel 999 2 dann sagt er an invalid ip endpoint hat been hat hess was was was specified
sagt er auch genau das funktioniert und nein wir machen da jetzt kein comment hin das versteht
jeder der nur halbwegs beiverstand ist sogar ich den halben jahr wenn ich das sehe schon spät
also nicht so spät ok ip endpoint also wir wissen jetzt wo wir uns hin verbinden wollen das doch
schon mal nice das die halbe miete so wir machen jetzt mal einen test mit einem command danach
machen wir einen test mit mehreren commands und dann müssen wir das über irgendeine queue
serialisieren dass es immer nur nacheinander ausgeführt wird da muss jetzt da muss jetzt
mal gucken wie man das wie man das richtig machen ok also public void keine ahnung send
command einfach mal string command string gut so rufen wir das mal auf
send commands so get betrieb betrieb art so damit kommen damit kommen jetzt hier anfangen
gleich mit mit pains champion englisch geschichte get betrieb art also das bekommen wir jetzt hier
übrigens ich kann euch neuest auch noch ein cooles feature zeigen das gibt es aber schon
eine weile man kann sagen dort net watch run und passt mal auf was jetzt passiert wenn ich das mache
ende hier jetzt mal was in main guckt mal ich schreibe jetzt eine vier rein und speichere und
beim wird automatisch ausgeführt und neu what the fuck ist das noch ein bisschen verbackt
ist das noch ein bisschen verbackt mit dort net 6 das passiert nämlich normalerweise nicht
und da fünf ich weiß genau dass es funktioniert ok das ist anscheinend nur wenn ich in main was
ändere ok es ist broken es ist broken unter dort net 6 kaputt keine chance
es geht unter fünf ich weiß dass es geht ich benutze das auch öfters also normalerweise wie
gesagt wir verwenden hier eine beta preview version ja es gibt noch gut schein bei hetzner
ausrufe zeichnen hetzner im chat 20 euro startgut haben sichern exzellent der löwensteiner ist da
morgen ok das ist verbackt was auch immer ok send send kommand das heißt wir müssen die
kram jetzt von von von hand ausführen watch geweck kein watch watch muss raus so gut also
jetzt haben wir das kommand jetzt müssen wir uns verbinden zu der zu der heizung bzw nicht
direkt zur heizung zu zu dem telnet endpoint unten im keller das mal überlegen wie machen
wir das jetzt am besten mit nem tcp kleint würde ich sagen mit nem tcp kleint würde ich sagen machen
würde also lass mal ausprobieren war kleint gleich kleint immer best new tcp kleint so endpoint endpoint ip
endpoint ok wir können jetzt noch was wir können noch was noch was ein auch ein halbwegs neues
feature verwenden using war kleint was das jetzt macht ist am ende dieser methode ruft
er automatisch wenn das auto scope geht dispose auf und dispose schließt die tcp verbindung
und gibt alle unmanaged ressourcen frei der gute besserung look place herzmuskel entzündung ist
richtiger sack einer der leute die ich auf twitter und folge beziehungsweise einer der wenigen die
ich so aus e-sport und youtube und sonst was kenne mit denen ich mich mal real life getroffen
habe der hatte auch eine herzleistet herzmuskel entzündung nach seiner corona impfung also es
gibt ja ein paar leute die ich von diesem ganzen online zirkus hier l kenne ausgerechnet hat es
einfachen getroffen so also jetzt haben wir den tcp kleint damit können wir jetzt dinger machen
auf dem telnet endpoint das heißt wir machen da jetzt mal so was wie was kann man damit machen
mit dem tcp kleint nicht so so raar geschichten so raar geschichten mache ich normalerweise
receive timeout send timeout was haben wir denn hier connect connect muss man aber nicht von
hand machen get stream get stream ist gut das brauchen wir wir brauchen den stream wir wollen
das sachen wir wollen da sachen lesen von der heizung also wir wollen jetzt quasi das da das
da mal hier über das program machen also stream jetzt jetzt jetzt lesen wenn man was weil wenn
man sich darauf connectet das erste was man bekommt ist vctrld das wollen wir jetzt mal einlesen ob
das funktioniert also probieren wir aus irgendwie so es kann weil stream reads read read bite wir
lesen jetzt einfach mal eine eine sache ein und gucken ob es dann hängt ist ja auch weil
tru ich will einfach nur gucken ob da was sinnvolles bei rauskommt read bite 1 2 3 ja ja ist ja gut was
was wo ist das problem cannot assign requested address warum so richtig
ah endpoint der will das lokal aufmachen wait a minute der will das der will das lokal aufmachen
das ist raus der will das endpoint ist falsch oder oh nee ja moment warum macht er das denn lokal
auf das ist ja pence champ ich will es nicht lokal endpoint haben gibt's gibt's gibt's gibt's
in remote endpoint ja das ist ja das ist ja pence champ implementierung ich mein das ist
ja kacke auch mal google befragen lp endpoint remote aber man kann connect sagen ok connect
ist auch in ordnung leint connect und da darf ich das da darf ich das jetzt angeben oder jetzt
jetzt ist ok das sollte jetzt funktionieren das kann ich was auslesen hey wir lesen bites aus
perfekt abbrechen hey max schreibst du mit zehn fingern ich kann mit zehn fingern schreiben aber
nicht sonderlich schnell ich bin immer noch ein auf die tastatur spicker so read bites
konvertieren wir das mal zu zu einem character dass man den kram li dass man den kram lesen kann also
wvc trl d foggers funktioniert guckt hell net vc trl d quitter goodbye so genau passen ist auch
nicht in ihr ding gut das funktioniert also wie können wir das jetzt ordentlich auslesen also wir
haben wir haben die verbindung wir haben die telnet verbindung wir haben den stream in den
stream können wir reinschreiben und lesen das heißt wir brauchen jetzt einen reader da kann
ich euch auch noch einen tipp geben ich wusste dass selbst eine weile nicht dass es das gibt
oder besser gesagt ich wusste das auch noch gar nicht so lange ist es her dass ich festgestellt
dass sowas gibt früher habe ich immer stream reader verwendet stream reader ist eine klasse
die ziemlich praktisch ist wenn man text einlesen will wir wollen zwar text einlesen aber wir wollen
auch binary sachen einlesen wir wollen nicht nur text einlesen so und stream reader hat ein paar
probleme ja du kannst bei stream reader zum beispiel sagen read line das problem ist wie ihr hier
seht ja es ist keine line das hier ist keine textzeile da fehlt das new line da schreibt
dahin vctrld ja spitze klammer zu größer zeichen was auch immer und dann macht der
canoe line und da hat da hat stream reader choose my name nicht spoilern da hat stream
reader ein problem wenn ich das jetzt versuche zum beispiel wenn ich sag reader read line dann
werdet ihr sehen es hängt einfach es hängt und es passiert gar nichts der wartet jetzt ich kann
übrigens noch ein timeout setzen das sollte ich vielleicht an der stelle machen read timeout keine
ahnung ist das ist das millisekunden ist das millisekunden in millisekunden 5 sekunden
read timeout und wir machen auch 5 sekunden 5 sekunden right timeout so und jetzt wird man
sehen wenn wenn 5 sekunden sind rückte ab geht nicht weil er findet kein new line
natürlich was wir jetzt machen könnten ist eine wildschlag also die die die variante wie ich es
früher gemacht hätte wäre sowas hier in der richtung gewesen ja ich bastel jetzt immer so
oft auf die schnelle so da werde ich jetzt mal stream read byte string und bloß gleich irgendwie
sowas hier irgendwie sowas in der richtung ja und dann if also nee das muss man anders machen
if das da eingelesen gleich dem da dann dann break oder so sowas in der richtung man könnte das
oben nee das könnte man nicht oben reinschreiben so in der so in der richtung hätte ich das
wahrscheinlich gemacht als ich noch nicht wusste dass es binary reader gibt aber ihr seht das
funktioniert auch wie kontrolle also von der idee klappt die manuelle variante natürlich auch ja
ich scheiß jetzt mal auf string bilder du hast recht eigentlich dann mit einem string bilder
wobei es bei einem so kurzen string vollkommen egal ist ob string oder string bilder oder was
was oder die ganz coolen leute verwenden ja nicht mal ein string bilder die verwenden span heute
mittlerweile mit der mein gaming dankeschön für den sub und ein gegift und satan perli
huge gifts hier heute danke danke leute was in string bilder also jetzt muss ich ich finde
das cool man kann hier immer so ein bisschen dotnet und c sharp grundlagen machen also ein
string in c sharp oder man muss eigentlich sagen in dotnet ist immutable das heißt wenn man einen
string ändert legt das immer einen neuen string an also wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel sagen wenn ich
jetzt so was hier mache plus gleich lull dann hängt er nicht etwa lull hier hinten dran an
ja sondern der erzeugt hier raus einen neuen string und fügt die zwei sachen zusammen das heißt für
jedes mal wo ich hier sagen string plus gleich legt er in wirklichkeit einen neuen string an
das ist natürlich performance mäßig wenn man das oft aus wird nicht sonderlich gut dafür gibt es
string bilder lull b bilder und der ist quasi ein managet buffer das ist quasi ein managet buffer
für strings wo das eben nicht passiert sie ist es genau das gleiche aber es ist schneller so aber
das brauchen wir alles gar nicht weil wir nehmen nicht stream reader sondern wir nehmen binary reader
das wusste ich noch vor ganz gar zu aller gar zu langer zeit gar nicht dass es das gibt erst
als ich nach genau so einem problem gesucht habe hat einer auf stack overflow was was sonst geschrieben
wie wäre es denn wie wäre es dann mit binary reader oder habe ich auch was ernsthaft binary reader
gibt es so und da kann es jetzt solche sachen machen wie read und hast du ganz viele ganz viele
varianten read chance zum beispiel so und da kann ich jetzt sagen sieben chance und passt mal auf
fertig der macht das für mich das ist viel viel praktischer wenn es nicht wirklich gut formatiert
das genormtes zeug ist was du ausliest als stream reader ich hätte mich früher geärgert das
stream reader so dummes und er hätte das von hand gemacht aber jetzt nachdem ich weiß dass
binary wieder da ist ist das natürlich august was ist dann mit dem output was für einem output
was meinste der output kommt hier raus geht ins right line und kommt auf die konsole der länger
ist als sieben der bleibt im stream stehen der wäre noch da also im angenommen ich leh ich lese
nur vier aus da kriege ich halt die ersten die ersten vier und der rest steht da noch drin
halt nicht ausgelesen kann ich dir kann ich dir auch zeigen so guck mal hier stream position falls das
geht ich bin mir nicht sicher ob bei einem netzwerk stream position funktioniert okay aber
habe ich nix gesagt ja aber das steht dann noch im stream drin ein bisschen laut auf einmal oder
kurz skippen skip champ keine seek operations ja bei einem netzwerk stream ist irgendwie klar
dass der keine seek operations kann genau genau guck ich kann zum beispiel einmal vier bytes
einlesen einmal drei bytes einlesen siehst du das kommt alles nacheinander raus so aber wenn
ich jetzt noch mal drei bytes was meint ihr was passiert wenn ich jetzt noch mal drei bytes einlesen
was was wird passieren ist so viel gibt es ja da nicht was meint der massive brainchats was
passiert exception timeout richtig ich lese das ein gibt das aus er versucht jetzt drei weitere
character zu lesen und fünf sekunden timeout connection timeout ich meine ich könnte das
jetzt ketschen und weitermachen aber das ist ja nicht nur zweck der sache an der stelle ok also
ich ich ich read ich read chance jetzt sieben also weiter im text wir verlassen wir verlassen uns
jetzt auch mal drauf dass das dass das so dass das so ist dass das sieben sind also ich überprüfe
jetzt hier den output mal an der stelle nicht dass da auch wie control die drinne steht so und jetzt
kommt das nächste problem jetzt müssten wir irgendwie das command reinschreiben also wir haben
jetzt das hier weg geredet und jetzt müssen sagen get betrieb art und dann enter drücken und dann
enter drücken so also ich könnte so was hier sagen wie right aber das sagt ziemlich aber
glücklicherweise gibt es nicht nur einen binary reader sondern einen binary writer man kann
damit auch reiten leider ist der binary writer kacke weil der binary writer hat ein problem oder
was heißt kacke aber hat hat ein paar probleme also es gibt es gibt so was wie right string also
das funktioniert aber der macht nicht das richtige es backt das backt irgendwie rum
bei der reitet nicht einfach nur die character rauf sondern er macht irgendwelche merkwürdigen
dinger das funktioniert nicht also der prefix das mit der länge irgendwie das liegt auch daran
weil das überhaupt nicht entkommen also weil er gar nicht weiß welches encoding er verwenden
sollte was ich machen kann ist also was ich jetzt schreiben muss ist ja ist ja folgendes ich müsste
jetzt schreiben get betrieb art get betrieb art und dann müsste ich dann müsste ich quasi bis
zum bis zum new line lesen aber das wird nicht funktionieren gibt es keine telnet library für
c sharp ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher selbst wenn wir eine telnet library hätten viel
komfortabler als das hier wird es wahrscheinlich anders sein weil der telnet ist keine wahnsinnige
abstraktion über so ein tcp so geht also das kann ich machen aber das funktioniert nicht weil
er nicht weiß welches encoding und pla und sonst was deswegen muss ich müsste ich müsste ich ihm
jetzt sagen right encoding ich muss ihm sagen welches also der muss ja wissen dass er das
übers netzwerk schreiben kann in welchem in welchem encoding er das senden soll ja also ich könnte
jetzt so was sagen wie encoding aski get bites das würde funktionieren jetzt schreibt er das
als byte array in den netzwerk stream das geht das würde funktionieren so kann ich euch auch
zeigen gleich gleich zeigen dass das dass das funktioniert was ist denn da was ist denn da die
antwort ww so also wir schreiben das jetzt rein sagen wir read reader read chars wir sagen jetzt
zwei und ich würde jetzt erwarten da kommt als antwort ww gucken wir mal ob das stimmt was ich
da gemacht habe ich habe vergessen ich habe vergessen korrekt chat ich habe vergessen
newline hinten dran zu machen der schickt es gar nicht ab aha ww funktioniert so jetzt ist das
nach des ist das ja hier vielleicht ein bisschen ein bisschen unhandlich deswegen können wir ein
weiteres nicht wirklich so neues die scharpfeature verwenden aber zumindest eins wo denke ich viele
die auch neu mit der sprache anfangen gar nicht so genau wissen wofür es gut ist nämlich extension
messers ich komme hier grad vor wieder wieder wieder tutorial tutorial max plus für programmier ja also
wir können jetzt wir können jetzt eine extension messer definieren dass wir zum beispiel in diesem
video nur ganz kurz gezeigt extension messers für scharpmethod ja genau das kann ich mich
gut vorstellen also was ja viel was ja viel cooler wäre anstatt übrigens sollte ich an
der stelle auch hier das übergebende command nehmen und nicht einfach mal so hier get get
betriebsart gucken ob es auch funktioniert sagt funktioniert noch ich mache mal dieses
1234 weg ist ziemlich doof und machen wir hier oben mal irgendwie so eine debug ausgabe
command übrigens auch in den halbwegs neues feature template strings weiß gar nicht ob
es offiziell template strings heißt also früher hätte ich das jetzt so gemacht hier guck plus
cmd also nehme string und command zusammen und gibt es aus aber wenn man mehrere sachen einsetzen
will und das formatieren will sind template strings viel praktischer dann macht man das
nämlich so so und wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht dass ich hier noch wahnsinnig viel anderes
formatieren will und mehrere sachen habe ist das natürlich viel praktischer baut euch das mal
zusammen mit mit append und plusse und sonst wie da ist das mit hier mit so einem interpolated
template string ist das schon nicer wann kommt der progress youtube channel glaube sowas werde ich
nicht machen es gibt da ich glaube eben es gibt auf deutsch da nicht so viele interessenten auf
youtube ich mache das lieber im stream da ist ja der massive q chat auch dabei es ist mir lieber
wenn der chat mit am start ist ja da kann der chat auch keck w wenn ich hier wieder am am
und kastieren bin keine ahnung habe was ich mache deutsche proga tutorials in pains die meisten
schon einfach dein massive englisch aus oh ja oh ja we are all sitting in one boat da hat die
welt drauf gewartet dass ich dass ich englische progress streams macht das also wenn dann müsste
man das aber zur marketing feature machen dass ich german accent habe oder sowas das müsste man
dann irgendwie mit einbauen das wirst muss man da irgendwie zum thema machen dieser stream ist
jetzt deutsch ok machen wir aber weiter es gibt ein nicht so neues feature in sie schafft was
aber halt glaube ich gerade leute die neu anfangen sich fragen wozu wozu braucht man das und das sind
extension methods und zwar was ich gerne schreiben würde wäre zum beispiel so was hier nicht
reit da wissen wir dass es nicht funktioniert und leider ist bei reit string auch schon belegt
darin ist gar nicht ich jetzt bloß nicht haf was zum teufel ist haf sind die string schon
belegt nee aber character array dass der wandel das wandel das wahrscheinlich um also was wir
jetzt machen können ist wir können extension method basteln also es wäre ja cool wenn ich
zum beispiel jetzt sowas hier schreiben könnte wenn ich jetzt hier schreiben könnte cmd plus
ulein und das würde einfach funktionieren aktuell funktioniert das nicht mal gucken
was eigentlich macht wenn ich das schreibe ja er kommt dann zurück er war weil das nicht
weil das weil das nicht versteht string value ja weil er in den mist schreibt also das ist
anscheinend schon überladen dafür wieso benutzt du nicht den stream writer dafür
das könnte man das könnte man an der stelle tatsächlich auch machen allerdings es kann sein
dass ich binary sachen nachher noch schreiben muss da bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher
also dass das ist schon belegt aber zumindest ist es eine gute gelegenheit mal extension methods
zu zeigen extensions so und da tue ich mir jetzt immer schwer was ich das aus dem kopf was ich
da was ich das static machen muss also ich glaube man braucht public static class extensions so und
jetzt kann man also es wäre ja cool wenn ich sowas hier machen könnte das die string oder so
das wäre ja cool wenn das funktioniert aber leider hat die binary writer methode keinen
ascii string deswegen kann man den einfach einbauen wenn es den nicht gibt und dafür sind
extension methods gut kann jetzt zum beispiel sagen ok ich würde gerne hier diese klasse noch
ein bisschen erweitern und zwar um eine methode right ascii string ok also sagen wir public da
bin ich mir kann sein ich die sonntag jetzt verkacke public static void ja right right ascii string
jetzt muss ich überlegen ist das ist das richtig ist das ist das richtig was ich da treibe wie
ging das jetzt noch mal man musste nämlich irgendwie binary writer ach nee warte mal wie
war das this binary writer war das na writer genau und dann waren wir hier string genau so
funktioniert das so und auf einmal sieht man guckt mal da das ding hat jetzt eine methode right
ascii string ohne dass wir die klasse an sich geändert haben haben wir die jetzt erweitert
mit extension methods so und jetzt kann ich hier zum beispiel sagen writer right und dann das was
ich mit meinen bytes gemacht habe so wunderbar und schon funktioniert und ich muss hier nicht
irgendwelche komischen spiritien machen funktioniert einfach neue jetzt hat das ding eine extra neue
methode von uns hier implementiert und es sieht aus als würde es zu dieser klasse gehört das ist
übrigens ein feature was ich mega nice finden würde für c++ ihr wisst ich bin überhaupt kein
c++ fan aber ich bin manchmal gezwungen was microcontroller angeht c++ zu machen und nachdem
c++ jeder jedes framework alles mögliche default stringklassen mitbringt wäre das ganz ganz cool
ja wenn man das wenn man das erweitern könnte einfach einfach stringklasse erben bringt ja
nix das ändert ja die anderen metoden nicht was rückgabeparameter und so angeht wo ich
nichts damit zu tun habe wird das nicht spagetti code nee das ist doch viel besser lesbar als hier
irgendwie anderen anderen kram man könnte man könnte sich jetzt natürlich auch ein binary reader
quasi subklassen und das da implementieren aber warum wie funktioniert das wenn dependencies auch
extension methoden definieren die die gleiche signatur haben wenn du die dann darfst du dann
darfst du nur dass das in die usings schreiben was du benutzen willst wenn du zwei falls import also
bin ich mir relativ sicher ich habe es jetzt nicht ausprobiert in letzter zeit wenn du zwei usings
drinne hast die die gleichen extension message importieren für die gleichen klassen dann mit
den gleichen overloads dann wird er wahrscheinlich sagen duplicate definition oder sowas gehe ich
mal von aus ja aber meistens exportiert man den kram hier gar nicht also wenn ich irgendein
nugget package oder so verwende dann sind da keine extension methods drin für standardklassen
oder so höchstens was für eigene die die mitbringen also das ist nix weil im angenommen
ich würde es jetzt irgendwie als library exportieren da würde ich wahrscheinlich meine
internen extensions da nicht anpreisen verwende die jetzt so right ask ist übrigens das ist an
der stelle richtig wir könnten wahrscheinlich auch einen stream writer verwenden das würde
wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren das testen wir jetzt mal right line da kann ich wahrscheinlich
sogar das backslash n weglassen gucken wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert
ich weiß aber nicht warum ehrlich gesagt
da habe ich jetzt keinen plan warum das nicht funktioniert ich hätte eigentlich gedacht
nachdem der chat das hier vorgeschlagen hat stream weiter klingt sinnvoll dass das mehr
oder weniger äquivalent zu dem ist was wir da vorhin gebastelt haben
also stream writer geht nicht ich habe keine ahnung warum das nicht funktioniert vielleicht
auch wegen dem encoding weil der nicht weiß was er reiten soll oder keine ahnung wird
das ein addon für home assistant so ein bisschen ein bisschen es wird mqtt autodiscovery verwenden
für heizungsstelle da bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher warum es nicht funktioniert ehrlich
gesagt da weiß ich jetzt aber wisst ihr was wir können dann mal reingucken was es unter
der haube macht right span append new line true stream reader nutzt bei default utf 8
das ist das problem deswegen geht das nicht kann man ist kann man das encoding umstellen
das habe ich noch nicht gemacht einmal kann man irgendwie entkommen
encoding ascii ok jetzt funktioniert wahrscheinlich
oder auch nicht das würde ich eigentlich erwarten dass
der das jetzt für mich macht aber aber ok ich habe keinen schimmer warum das nicht
geht weiß nicht was das stream writer da noch haben will wahrscheinlich wartet er
auf den land keine ahnung ich bin meine extension messen messen deutlich praktischer ehrlich
gesagt als als das ja können wir mal probieren vielleicht so ah ok wir müssen ihm explizit
sagen alter sende mal ansonsten baffert er das erstmal ok aber ich muss ehrlich sagen
ich finde mein schöner also guck mal hier müssen wir encoding angeben hier müssen wir
irgendwie reiter flaschen und sonst wie wir machen einfach ich mache meinen binary writer
mit meiner extension messen viel besser right ascii string cmd plus new line es gibt auch
autoflasch ach so moment muss ja mal ein stream stream writer auto autoflasch jetzt
aus der value indicating das brauchen wir aber alles net ich kann einfach meine extension
messen verwenden das funktioniert das lassen wir jetzt so besser max grad meins ist besser
was so weiter weiter im text meins ist besser ok wir sind heute wir sind heute huge huge
geschwind wir haben ganze fünf ich bin jetzt zwei stunden und wir haben ganze zwölf zeilen
programmiert 13 14 15 16 aber ich bin ja relativ viel am erklären außerdem haben wir die ersten
stunden erste stunde gar nichts gemacht in der richtung ok also weiter im text wir haben
es jetzt geschrieben wir haben das ausgelesen wunderbar was wir jetzt noch bräuchte ist
wir wissen ja nicht wie lange die antwort ist wir wissen ja nicht wie lange die antwort
ist weil sagen wir so bei get get betrieb art ist die antwort zwei zeichen aber bei
get moment was war das get temp ww ist das war jetzt als nächstes das ist so monach
s alter wenn sich das überlegt hat gehört geschlagen ist die antwort viel viel länger
und wir wissen wir wissen nicht wie lang das heißt wir können das so gar nicht auslesen
weil der weiß ja nicht der weiß ja nicht wie lang wie lang das ganze ist also jetzt
könnten wir noch einen stream reader verwenden oder so was in der richtung der das macht
da machen wir aber wieder eine neue extension method read bis end line ja das könnten wir
machen aber da bräuchte ich jetzt quasi hier noch zusätzlich was das machen wir alles
in in eine weitere extension method ich bin gerade so am am extenden dann passt das wir
denn das einfach read line binary reader zurück kommt ein string massive massive extending
hier und da machen wir jetzt einfach unter der haupe einen stream reader draus stream
reader das ist wahrscheinlich nicht schön aber es ist trotzdem gut lesbar so reader
stream stream ist es so using nee nein nein nein leute wenn ich da ein using da vormach
dann break das ganze weil mit einem using würde das stream reader hier den stream schließen
und den brauche ich ja noch geht ja nicht also dürfen wir nicht dürfen wir nicht klausen
stream reader in das jetzt read line read line wunderbar lein lein return lein wunderbar
was hat er jetzt für schmerzen possible null reference who cares warum ich mich nicht wir
haben kein null null ist nicht existent das lasse ich jetzt einfach so gibt es nicht null
ist out out out of scope gibt es nicht für deinen stream reader gibt es ein extra parameter
lief open tatsächlich müssen wir gucken lief open oder oder extra extra property da dran
wie viel überladung hatten das ding lief open tatsächlich was cool das ist sehr nice
aus null gibt es wirklich nicht weil vorne vorher ein timeout kommt tatsächlich ja du
hast recht es gibt kein null entweder redet er das oder er kackt ab jazubi story montag
oder dienstag ich habe aufgenommen aber das war mir zu spät heute schon warum nicht return
read line ja das stimmt das ist bescheuert brauche man nicht kann man so machen ja ja
null reference keck weight was schlägt er mir eigentlich vor ach so ich kann reff nein
nein null reference ignorieren wir jetzt einfach mal aber nicht over overrated she baited so
wunderbar also können wir jetzt sagen a reader a read habe ich das genannt read line oder
nicht ach so binary reader read line und das sollte jetzt die komplette zeile ausspuckt
egal wie lang schauen wir mal es ist eine äußerst sinnlose extension method aber es
wird funktionieren zeigt mal her bam zack funktioniert so und jetzt können wir auch
gleich mal ausbringen ob das mit anderen sachen funktioniert wir machen jetzt send command
jetzt ww ne get temp ww ist und get temp ww ist 55.000000 grad Celsius nice ja das sollte
das sollte tatsächlich den using sollte den using da vorkommen ja das ist nicht verkehrt
das ist schon richtig wahrscheinlich wäre das nicht verkehrt hier noch den using dran
zu hauen auf der anderen seite ne das using brauchen wir wahrscheinlich nicht der tcp
client wird das post das stream wird geklaust ist das der temperatur warmwasser ist wert
ja ist es oder muss man bei einer reader das pausen macht doch eh nichts das ding was
macht denn das ist post lief auf dem stream klaus ne das müssen wir nicht das pausen
das macht nix das kann so bleiben wobei er wahrscheinlich sogar probleme bekommt wenn
ich beides dispose weil er das das hier zu macht das hier nacheinander zu macht und eins
eins ist halt zuerst scheinen zu funktionieren das post ist blut aber wir können auch wir
können das auch das pausen das das pausen war halt auch gut können commands mehr als
eine zeile return nein können sie nicht können können sie nicht das geht nicht so wunderbar
jetzt wird es aber noch ein bisschen advanceder weil kurz überlegen wie wir das jetzt wie
wir das jetzt so in die richtige reinfolge in die richtige reinfolge bringen string
return type und zwar ja was was der reader geredet hat also nein nein nein wir wollen
hier keinen also was der reader geredet hat also sprich send command und wir kriegen dann
response antworten so ja das ist eigentlich ganz ok das kann man so lassen gut das nächste
ist ich möchte ja das ding aufrufen können mit mehreren commands aber das war jetzt ja
eigentlich nur mal der versuch wie kriegen wir das prinzipiell ausgelesen wie gesagt
man kann ja anstatt das da nacheinander zu machen man kann das kommer getrennt übergeben
also ich kann ich kann zum beispiel sowas hier machen nee was denn was ich erzähle in
der tcp ich muss es einfach in der gleichen tcp session abfragen das geht glaube ich
bis zu 20 commands da gab es irgendein limit maximal 20 commands die ich da übergeben
kann und dann macht er das in einer session das heißt eigentlich könnte ich jetzt anstatt
sowas machen wie send commands send command könnte ich sowas machen wie send commands
also send commands oder wir machen wir machen wir machen das anders wir machen public string
send nee void void wir testen send commands so und jetzt können wir ein weiteres feature
mal ausprobieren wenn man hardcore read muss das sein ja muss es sind immer exakt 7 ansonsten
darf es abkacken mach doch den connect einfach im constructor nee ich will dass das hier
aufgemacht wird und hier wieder geschlossen wird ich will das nicht auflassen das soll
genau connecten für den run dieser methode mehr nicht
komm wir bauen wir funktionieren das doch um send commands ups send commands jetzt kannst
du fife hat den socket static für die ganze klasse der für jedes mal den socket wieder
benutzen falls er getimed ist ich erstelle einfach so neu ein gutes so send commands
so wir können jetzt ein weiteres feature benutzen und zwar wir wollen jetzt ja eigentlich sowas
hier machen aber der nachteil davon ist damit ich das jetzt korrekt aufrufen kann müsste
ich sowas hier machen was nicht so schön ist ich müsste sagen quasi send commands new
string array und dann sowas hier machen ja das ist nicht schön kenntbetriebs betriebart
was man machen kann ist kann sagen params was params erlaubt ist ich kann beliebig viele
parameter übergeben von diesem typ was unter der haube zu einem string array gemacht wird
aber wo ich kein string array als parameter übergeben muss also ich kann jetzt hier mehrere
parameter vom gleichen typ übergeben und dann macht mir unter der hauben string array
raus das ist glaube ich drinnen seit c sharp 1 oder so das gibt es schon ewig und ist
an einigen stellen wirklich wirklich praktisch so also get temp ww ist haben wir jetzt das
heißt wir können an der stelle einfach eine schleife machen würde ich sagen reader und
anstatt anstatt mich machen wir hier kurz weit rein dass nix kaputt geht so und anstatt
der an hier machen wir einfach eine schleife drumherum hier for each commands ne wie habe
ich es genannt cmd ich nenne es mal commands die weg ja ja das funktioniert hier oben nicht
mehr so for each command in commands aber diesen krempel ausführen wenn ich das richtig
programmiert habe dann sollte das eigentlich auch einfach so funktionieren gucken wir mal
gucken wir mal ob das klappt da sollte jetzt beide beider commandos ausführen
ja macht er füllt beide commandos aus nacheinander und sogar relativ schnell 74 grad Celsius und
warmwasser das ist schon mal nice so jetzt kann ich mehrere commandos nacheinander ausführen
jetzt gibt es nur ein kleines problem wo ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher bin wie ich das
lösen werde denn oder lass mal überlegen gibt es überhaupt ein problem ja es gibt
ein problem wenn ich das wenn ich das aus mehreren threats aufrufe aber ist das wirklich
ein problem mache ich das überhaupt warum sollte ich so was komisches machen ja doch
das ist ein problem ich muss das später eventuell aus mehreren threats aufrufen weil man kann
ja dann im home assistant also es gibt es gibt im home assistant dann ein knopf so es gibt
in meinem home assistant dann ein knopf und mit dem knopf kann ich die heizung ja ja bla bla bla
bla add card switch nee habe ich habe ich irgendwie den switch entity ich habe keinen switch wo ich
euch das zeigen kann ich zeige euch das mal im home assistant demo ich habe dann in meinem
dashboard so einen schalter für die heizung so sowas hier zum beispiel ein schalter für die
heizung habe ich dann in meinem dashboard so und wenn das commando jetzt schalten reinkommt dann
kann es sein dass zufälligerweise grad der refresh läuft der keine ahnung alle zwei minuten die werte
neu abliefert neu ausliest und dann geht es definitiv kaputt wenn zwei dieser sachen parallel
laufen dann wird es kaputt gehen denke ich mal oder auch nicht ich habe keine ahnung ob das mehrere
sachen gleichzeitig kann was passiert das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren was passiert wenn ich
mehrere sachen gleichzeitig gleichzeitig gleichzeitig darauf connecten lasse und abfrage
geht nicht leute guck man kann immer nur eine eine connection haben
ist broken das ist broken mehr als eine connection ist rip
warum verwendest du telnet ist doch unsicher weil das oldschool shit ist das geht nur über telnet
habe ich keine chance ach ja was übrigens kein problem ist das programm läuft im endeffekt ja
dann auf dem letzt also läuft ja auf dem gleichen programm läuft auf dem gleich auf der gleichen
hardware wie die heizungsverbindung ist also da geht gar nichts übers netzwerk zum testen mache
ich jetzt übers netzwerk also es sind dann rein localhost verbindung da ist das mit telnet schlimm
das ding kann schlicht nur greifen nix anderes als telnet gibt es nicht
so was wir jetzt machen könnten ist wir müssen das jetzt irgendwie so ansatzweise thread safe
machen kann man hier irgendwie schon timeout setzen ist das ist das in millisekunden
soll das das probieren das probieren jetzt mal aus das probieren jetzt mal aus was passiert wenn
ich jetzt sage task run task run wenn ich das jetzt zweimal ausführe was passiert dann ist dann rip
oder funkt oder oder geht das ist dann rip oder funktioniert wisst ihr was gibt zwar schönere
varianten aber das ist die einfachste jetzt mal gucken mal gucken was was passiert 2 1 mal gucken
was passiert ok es hat einfach funktioniert aber das eine nach dem anderen ja sobald sich der
hier sobald sich der erste disconnected geht der zweite dran also das könnte man das könnte man
wahrscheinlich sogar so lassen ok wir testen wir testen noch mal was wir machen mal ein paar mehr
sachen wir machen mal 10 10 verbindungen das spackt dann irgendwann und kackt das wahrscheinlich
voll ab achso nein das funktioniert jetzt ja nicht weil das immer das letzte ist das vergesst
leute das geht geht so nicht muss man abbrechen mal abbrechen da müssen wir jetzt kann man da
machen naja eigentlich können wir das so lassen anscheinend anscheinend kann das das handeln also
ich meine da macht nicht mehrere verbindungen da wartet einfach bis die andere verbindung
fertig ist nachdem das nicht so lange dauert ist das ist das ist scheint mehr in ordnung zu
sein ja wir können aber einfach der vollständigkeit halber wir haben jetzt nicht mehr so viel zeit
heute abend mal kurz gucken ob ich das irgendwie sehr realisiert bekommen würde mit irgendeiner
queue oder so bald bettke er hat nur die hälfte gemacht oder 2103 6 noch stimmt er hat nicht
alles gemacht das ist vorher das ist wahrscheinlich vorher getimed outet na gut wenn ich es erwarte
dann dann klappt das ganze hier natürlich nicht ist das getimed outet vorher mal gucken ob das
irgendeine ob das irgendwelche exceptions schmeißt 0 2 aha connection time ok also wenn man zu wenn
man zu multithreaded das macht dann teile oder das ok also also macht es doch einen sinn das
ist ein bisschen zu sehr realisieren wir lassen wir lassen das hier mal wir lassen das hier mal
gucken ob das nie wird kommet ihr das doch aus gucken ob das funktioniert wie könnte man das
jetzt machen also von der idee her bräuchten wir jetzt irgendwie noch eine neue methode die
dafür sorgt dass alle kommandos der reihe nach sequenziell abgearbeitet werden und nicht irgendwie
neue mehr verbindung oder sonstige sachen man könnte auch sich überlegen ob er sagt rios
irgendwie bis die queue leer ist mal gucken also static tcp connection ich weiß nicht ob das so
eine gute idee ist das ganze offen zu lassen das hat probleme wenn zu viel offene verbindungen
sind das spackt rum das hatte ich das hatte ich schon mal also wenn die verbindung zu lang offen
ist dann teile oder das irgendwann und der dieses telnet ding nimmt gar nichts neues mehr an also
was wir jetzt machen also ich bastel jetzt einfach mal was mal gucken ob das funktioniert wir brauchen
sowas hier wie public wo ich sowas wie queue commands mal das gleiche hier queue commands
so und jetzt müssen wir dafür sorgen dass das alles schön eingereitet wird und sequenziell
sequenziell durchläuft so da war jetzt mal ein private message queue oder sowas oder du sendest
die commands einfach bis sie mal durchkommen ja das ist das ist aber die low brain variante
das machen wir nicht also private was nehmen wir oh leute wir machen richtig pleading edge
technologie wobei das stimmt nicht das ist schon eine weile drin wir nehmen channel channel ist
jetzt neu seit c sharp dotnet dotnet 3 1 wann seit wann gibt es channels channel ja was muss
man in den channel rein strings ne tasks müssen da glaub rein je nachdem wie ich das mache
ok was lasst mal überlegen wie machen wir das jetzt hier ok das nennen wir jetzt irgendwie command
queue gleich new ne das geht ja so nicht channel create unbonded task ob das funktioniert was ich
da so zurecht baue ich habe da so ich habe da so ich habe da so meine zweifel ok neben
q klasse warum channel ist doch hier das neueste big brain ding von microsoft channels sind genau
für sowas gedacht sagt zumindest microsoft ok also jetzt haben wir irgendwie queue commands
command queue so das heißt ich bekomme jetzt hier die commands von der idee her müsste ich
jetzt ja die hier reinschreiben die müsste ich in den task packen hier ob das funktioniert
die müsste ich quasi in den task reppen hier uns dann dort ein rein und hier oben einen
task starten der im hintergrund immer überwacht ob was neues reinkommt channel quasi wie
executor service in java ich habe keine ahnung was denn executor service in java ist also
ich muss jetzt sowas hier machen wie command q new task achso moment moment add add add
writer writer yeah try it try right so new task so und da drinnen ruf ich dann dieses send commands
ding auf gibt das sinn was ich hier baue überhaupt chat sagt jetzt gleich nein und sagt die legs
critical information was ist ein channel das ist eine queue das ist eine queue die besonders
darauf ausgelegt ist es sind wait und und viele multithreaded dinger zu verwenden das ist der
neueste shit von microsoft ich weiß auch nicht genau was der große vorteil dagegen ist wahrscheinlich
die wahrscheinlich die erst die die die es sind ab hier im vergleich zu normalen queues ja
müssen wir mal bei microsoft gucken can be made read only ok so und jetzt muss ich die ganze zeit
in der endlosschleife gucken ob es ob es neue sachen in dieser command queue gibt also task
ran so weil mit weil ging das nicht wie war das command q reader read all async genau also vor
brauche eine vorschleife vor read all async command achso das ist das ist ja alles also
ist jetzt brauchen wir async await ok so rum jetzt jetzt wird es aber richtig jetzt wird
richtig fortschrittlich hier ich habe da schon ein constructor aber ja stimmt ich habe schon
einen dann muss das dann muss das nicht da rein sondern muss da oben rein und das muss da hoch
dass es das schöner ist so das muss da hoch warum kann ich keine zeilen verschieben was ist hier
los normalerweise kann man mit alte zeilen verschieben das habe ich nicht eingestellt
so und jetzt sagen wir da drin einfach nur command start await command
das müsste jetzt eigentlich funktionieren also von der idee her müsste das jetzt
folgendermaßen funktionieren ich rufe q commands auf der wrapped den eigentlichen
aufruf für diese telnet geschichte in den task und dann läuft auf einem separaten thread eine
schleife die endlos guckt gibt es in dieser q neue elemente und wenn ja dann startet es
einen nach dem anderen und wartet bis es fertig ist und dann macht es den nächsten also das
müsste jetzt eigentlich multi threading safe sein was ich hier basteln hoffe ich mal ein low
bob fragt was das geben soll ja ich will meine heizungssteuerung über mqtt discovery in home
assistant reinbringen das funktioniert bisschen neue instanz erstelle das ist richtig aber dann
das sei mal so dass das nicht ist instanz übergreifend multi threading safe ist das
kann ja keiner erwarten cancellation tocken aber wer hält sich mit so einfach keinen einfachen
sachen aus wo wird command start definiert in der task klasse ist schon eingebaut ich will dass
ich das automatisch announced über mqtt dass ich dann in meinem home assistant drin stehen
habe den sensor für wassertemperatur einen switch für heizung an aus und so was dass es komplett
automatisch discovered wird dass das jemanden das sport machen kann und gut ist über die home
assistant mqtt discovery so also das müsste jetzt eigentlich funktionieren was ich gebaut
habe probieren wir probieren wir das doch mal aus ob das jetzt klappt aber wir machen nicht
send commands wir machen jetzt q commands und jetzt schauen wir mal ob das klappt
chat prediction aber prediction kommen wir benutzen mal wir müssen mal features predictions
vorhersage starten wird es funktionieren ja nein bm gucken was der chat dazu sagt
wird es funktionieren funktioniert vermutlich ist aber irgendwie eine eklige lösung ja naja
wobei so eklig wenn ich das gar nicht das ist halt background background was wird es
da anders machen das ist das erste was mir spontan eingefallen ist wir zünden das über
irgendeine q was ist rausgekommen ich habe jetzt gar nicht geguckt moment ich kann nachgucken
slash prediction jetzt 96 69 69 sagen es wird funktionieren ne also ich bin da offen für
andere lösungen also wenn du eine gute idee hast schieß los ja das muss nicht so bleiben
wie ordnest du dann eigentlich die rückgabe werte ja gar nicht gerade rückgabe rückgabe
werte gibt es nicht das ist overrated zurzeit das muss ich mir noch überlegen task starten
sofort ne task starten nicht sofort das starten erst nach start es sei denn ich mache es mit
task start dann starten sie sofort es gibt eine neue kategorie du hättest es mit action
und task completed source gemacht also du meinst ja gut aber an welcher stelle ach so ja das
hätte man auch machen können dass ich hier kein task übergeben sondern du meinst dass
ich hier eine action übergebe dir das funktioniert genauso gut du hast voll und ganz recht ich
muss es nicht in task reiten ich kann das mit action machen weil ich es hier sequenziell
abarbeite das tut als action ganz genauso ich brauche überhaupt kein task task ist
komplett plaudet und overrated hier an der stelle jetzt ja brauche ich gar nicht aber
wir testen es erstmal funktioniert ja gut doch es funktioniert der hat zwar einen fehler
bekommen aber er führt alle 10 aus das ist funktioniert es funktioniert dass der bei
der übertragung ab und zu mal fehler haben kann das liegt an der heizung da kann ich
ja nichts für 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ja 10 10 ausgaben das hat funktioniert das ist nicht
gekrascht durchgelaufen das hatte zweimal übertragungsprobleme aber das kann ja passieren
also das kann er passieren also prediction ist ok übrigens den wer hat es geschrieben
tschüss man hat recht das mit dem task ist komplett komplett sinn sinnlos das ist komplett
kompletter schwachsinn wir können da
wir können da einfach einen ganz normalen callback draus machen wir brauchen das gar
nicht was ist mit dem task können wir uns können wir uns komplett komplett schenken
wir können einfach sagen new action haben wir die metode mit command an action kann
action parameter ich meine wir können genau das gleiche machen wie vorher nur mit dem
unterschied dass wir uns diesen ganzen dieses ganze task gedöns sparen weil wir brauchen
ja gar keine tasche machen das ja eh wir machen das ja eh komplett komplett sequenziell
so ach so wie kriege ich in das ding jetzt ein wie sorge ich jetzt dafür dass das wartet
bis das fertig ist kann ich eine action erwarten wie sorge ich jetzt dafür dass das nur funktioniert
da bin ich jetzt läuft das hier weiter macht es das jetzt parallel ja in in vogue ist sync
aber ich weiß nicht ob die schleife nicht weiter läuft gut die kann ja nicht weiter
laufen kann ja nicht weiter laufen so die die kann er nicht weiter laufen das das
test das test jetzt mal schnell die flur haben wir alle leute leute gleich ist gleich ist
bett bett geteim ich war mal kurz hier dieses zeugs da weg gleich ist bett geteim wir machen
jetzt einfach mehr kennen test und thread sleep sleep fünf sekunden ich will einfach
nur wissen ob das parallel läuft oder nacheinander ok das läuft das läuft schön nacheinander
alles und wunderbar das gefällt mir das ist gut ja das ist auf jeden fall eine schönere
lösung als das was ich damit irgendwie mit mit tasks konstruiert habe weil die task braucht
kein mensch ja so ist das choose my name ist das gefällt dir das jetzt so auch besser
ja so mit action kann man sogar sagen wir brauchen die action nicht mehr wir können
einfach sagen was was ist das ach so das geht ja weil ich actions nehme ja ok ergibt
sind ja nice dass das funktioniert jetzt tatsächlich nee ja das finde ich das finde ich das finde
ich schlecht das gefällt mir schon mal kannst du noch action erklären action ist das was
was in c++ quasi nen pointer auf ne funktion ist könnte man das so sagen also so ne art
function pointer anonymer function pointer auf irgendwas ausführbares weiß nicht wie
ich besser wie ich besser action beschreiben beschreiben soll also den delegate den delegate
ist ja quasi na gut es ist nicht wirklich ein function pointer es ist ja es ist ein
prototyp für nen function pointer delegate ist ja nur die definition also action ist
ja doch im prinzip ist das sowas wie ein function pointer action ist ein pointer auf
irgendwas ausführbares wo die signaturen stimmen also action t sowas hier zum beispiel
beschreibt hier kann ich jetzt jegliche funktion reinstecken die zum beispiel anonyme funktion
jegliche funktion reinstecken die keinen rückgabewert hat und keine parameter braucht
warum auch immer dass es nicht funktioniert so es ist egal ob ich da ne anonyme funktion
reinschreibe warum braucht man sowas hässliches zum beispiel wenn du ne warteschlange mit
funktions pointer machen willst zum beispiel hier weil wie willst du dort nen typ vergeben
für anonyme funktion du weißt ja nicht wie der typ heißt also steckst du die anonyme
funktion in der action rein oder kannst du sie cueen als zum später aufrufen du musst
ja den pointer irgendwo merken und das machst du in der action so also normale action normale
action ist ohne parameter und ohne rückgabewert mal als erklärt also ich könnte an der stelle
warum gibt es keinen typ für funktion ja das ist doch action ich zeig das mal also
du kannst jetzt an der stelle entweder lambda verwenden du könntest aber auch einfach sagen
hier keine ahnung public void public void keckw das geht ja nicht void void void keckw
und darauf kann das auch zeigen also das kann auch so ne funktion sein das kann alles quasi
auf alles zeigen wo die parameter stimmen so dann haben wir das nächste action zum beispiel
string wäre jetzt ein pointer auf ne funktion die einen string als parameter möchte oder
einen bull oder oder was auch immer so das wäre jetzt ne funktion die als ersten parameter
ein bull will oder als zweiten parameter ein string darauf passt natürlich keckw nicht
keckw hat keinerlei parameter aber wenn ich jetzt hier zum beispiel sage bull bull b und
string s dann funktioniert das ganze wieder so und wenn man jetzt was haben will was was
zurück gibt zum beispiel so dann wird man sehen dass das mit action nicht funktioniert
und dann kann man funk funk nehmen dann funktioniert das auch mit rückgabewert da muss ich jetzt
sagen der rückgabewert ist ein bull erster parameter ist bull zweiter parameter ist was
umgedreht ah es war aber umgedreht erst die parameter und das letzte template argument
ist der rückgabewert ja man könnte das übrigens ohne probleme selbst machen also das ist das
ist einfach nur so convenience mäßig eingebaut man könnte das man könnte das auch ohne
probleme selbst machen also ich könnte auch so was hier so was sagen wie kein delegate
boah jetzt ist jetzt jetzt hört es bei mir auf keine ahnung delegate bull wie gehen
es jetzt weiter keine ahnung function pointer mit bull und string so das ist quasi ok ich
muss hier glaube ich irgendwas angeben das ist quasi das gleiche nur dass du es halt
belandt hast ja der mag das übrigens nicht wegen wie immer dafür schmerzen hat ob ich
das nicht machen darf ok ganz unten darf ich das machen so und jetzt könnte ich hier genau
das gleiche sagen anstatt dass ich das vorgefertigte verwende sage ich jetzt function pointer kek
weh geht genauso nur dass ich dann jedes mal so musstest du das früher zu dotnet 2 zeiten
machen dass ich dann jedes mal so ein delegate typ bauen muss und damit ich das nicht machen
muss kann ich einfach action und funk verwenden ja also ich könnte mir auch anstatt dass
ich hier für meine queue action nehme könnte ich auch sagen ok ich nehme jetzt hier irgendwie
ich mache mir dann extra delegate für den halt benannt ist aber delegate ist quasi funktionsdefinition
genau das ist ein bisschen was ich würde mal sagen bisschen sowas wie typedef in c plus
plus was in der richtung aber c plus plus vergleiche sind generell pains jam weil c
plus plus einfach der ober abfuck ist hier kannst du alles reinstecken was als parameter
return wert buhl hat ersten parameter buhl zweiten parameter string das ist so wie nennt
man das in c prototyp oder so also alles was auf dieses signatur passt geht
und genau das brauchen wir hier auch an der stelle wir wollen ja nicht etwa das hier ausführen
sondern wir wollen eben sagen hey diese funktion hier also diese funktion die eigentlich nix
als call zu console rightline enthält wollen wir queueen und später dann hier der reihe
dann ausführen ja genau color force sowas sowas sowas in der richtung das das funktioniert
ja auch das funktioniert ja auch ich kann ja auch sagen funktionswahl bin ich mir gar
nicht sicher function pointer gleich das genau das kann ich auch sagen glaube ich oder auch
nicht ja genau guck das das das funktioniert genauso jetzt hat das ding halt einen namen
an der stelle hier das ist jetzt ein function pointer also sprich ich weiß aha es ist irgendeine
funktion dahinter die auf diese signatur passt und dem fall ist es hier diese anonyme funktionsaufruf
das ist eigentlich in den meisten sprachen ziemlich ähnlich nur dass eben in c sharp
haben sie gesagt hey wir machen sie leute ein bisschen einfacher und haben sowas wie
action und funkt standardmäßig standardmäßig drinnen damit ich nicht für jeden furz den
ich hier call becken will den eigenen function pointer und einen eigenen eigenen delegate
bauen muss kann sich habe eigentlich auch closures ja kannst du kannst du machen guck
hier war blub gleich eins blub wobei du da manchmal ein bisschen aufpassen muss je nachdem
an welcher stelle du das machst achso ja das macht es automatisch du musst nicht wie
in c plus plus solche komischen dinger hier machen was mega pence ist das macht da automatisch
du musst ein bisschen aufpassen zum beispiel wenn du sowas hier machst guck wenn du das
hier captures wenn du wenn du hier drinnen i captures von der schleife außen drum herum
dann gibt es natürlich probleme warum gibt es probleme weil es ja sein kann dass wenn
das hier ausgeführt wird i zu diesem zeitpunkt ja schon was ganz anderes ist so deswegen musst
du es einmal lokal zwischenspeichern und dann hier drinnen verwenden dass das funktioniert
dann dadurch dass du das hier einmal kopiert hier kopierst du dir das quasi einmal und
das verwendest du dann hier drinnen aber den zähler von einer schleife kannst du zwar
capturen aber es kommt meistens nicht das richtige raus das sind jetzt aber relativ
advanced details die wir haben normalerweise muss man sich da wenn man das halbwegs ordentlich
macht nicht so sehr nicht so viele gedanken drum machen weil das eines der großen vorteile
von c sharp ist dass die meisten sachen funktionieren so wie man denkt dass sie funktionieren im
vergleich zu c++ ja das verhält sich meistens so wie gedacht und es kommt dann auch am ende
das raus was man erwarten würde also sie scharpe ist echt eine sprache so für alltagsprobleme
die einfach das macht was man erwarten würde ja so siehts aus war ja mal mal hatte hatte
da ein back ich habe ihn so lange gesucht weil die dann immer ja ja das ist richtig
das sind richtige kack back sowas das doch nice ja also generell muss man aufpassen wenn
man auf das poste sachen zugreift also immer wenn man mult immer wenn man multithread gibt
es da gibt es da gibt es da probleme ja zum beispiel wenn ich eine controller action habe
in irgendeiner web application und dort sage ich da drinne keine ahnung task run und will
zwei sekunden später was triggern dann ist die ist dann ist die das schon durchgelaufen
und hat den datenbank kontext disposed und es crash da muss man aufpassen ja schon spät
leute ich würde sagen bettke time bettke time 22 16 wird zeit wupp bettke noch noch
noch wauke jetzt gleich bettke coding girl raid nein heute nicht heute raiden wir keine
coding grills
am morgen ersten arbeitstag nice easy win
also wir sehen uns bis morgen zu richtig easy durch pfeiffer chat natürlich
ja ich habe morgen frei weil montag ist montag habe ich immer frei ja nice wenn es euch gefallen
hat ich sollte den stream nicht immer so schnell ausmachen ja ich sage immer so nach dem motto
leute machts gut bis ncu wir können ruhig das können wir übrigens mal so standard machen
dass wir jeden stream so die letzten fünf minuten noch mal einfach einfach nix machen
ja musik ausmachen alle können sagen tschüss und dann gehe ich auf
aller weise haue ich immer instant ab der chat morgen der forms bild fixen weil ich
zu viel im pull request hatte
in den letzten fünf minuten ich glaube ich bin ein ganz schlechter als alle wobei wobei
ich bin dann eher so funktionen so nach dem motto ja das wäre jetzt hier der sma style
aber die richtig also nicht ausschließlich aber viele der großen erfolgreichen sma channels
sind ja in der regel hübsche grills es gibt ein paar kerle aber die meisten erfolgreichen
sind hübsche grills als ich wäre dafür wahrscheinlich nicht der richtige zumal man zumal ich mich
eigentlich vor die kamera stelle wir können im sma channel aus zeigt mal kurz wartet mal
was gibts denn da german sma comfy sunday what the fuck double elix elix was geht hier
wieder ab was geht hier wieder ab was geht hier bitteschön
das ist wirtschämt wirtschämt
also leute wir sehen uns bis denn cu